this is Joo podcast number
411 with Echo Charles and me Joo willink
good evening Ekko good
evening Vietnam was Far different from
Korea because I was there with one
Mission defeat the enemy as opposed to
the Chang P Fund in Korea I didn't have
the time energy or resources to support
the
community we were not there to win over
hearts and Minds we were fighting the
enemy in gorilla
War Lieutenant Colonel hackworth briefed
us on tactics he had learned in previous
deployments but this form of irregular
Insurgency Warfare was less predictable
and organized more chaotic and
treacherous as the leader of battle
company I was leading
operations in these gruesome firefights
in one particularly Ruth ruthless battle
with the Viet Kong we had many
killed there were three dead bodies at
my
feet a unit is most vulnerable right
after a victory it is just human nature
to let your guard down and breathe a
sigh of sigh of relief but as the guy in
charge the pro I knew that and acted
accordingly I was on my radio with my
platoon leaders barking out orders and
telling them to take care of their
wounded reorganize their units
redistribute ammunition and watch for
enemy Avenues of approach for a
Counterattack but suddenly I
stopped I glanced down at the enemy
bodies at my feet and realized that
something had happened to me something
had hardened my heart only moments
earlier these bodies were alive human
beings children of God with families and
loved ones they were fighting for
something equally as important to them
as I was fighting for
myself and yet I I was treating them
like bumps on a
log I then remembered Jesus's Sermon on
the Mount in which he told us to love
our
enemies so in the midst of all the
Mayhem the so-called fog of
battle I stopped and said a prayer for
the three Viet Kong and their
families but I was also saying a prayer
for
myself
and that right there is an excerpt from
a new book which is called faith family
and flag Memoirs of an unlikely American
Samurai
Crusader which was written by retired
Major General James moo mukama General
mukama was born in Chicago in
1944 the Second Son of Japanese
immigrants he was raised in a humble
Blue Collar family eventually joining
the Army where he served over 30 years
including tours in Korea and
Vietnam where he served as a company
Commander for one of my Heroes Colonel
David
hackworth his Awards include the Silver
Star three bronze star stars and the
purple heart he was the first Asian
American to command a US Army Division
and he has been on this podcast before
over 5 years years ago episode
124 but it is an honor to have him here
with us tonight to discuss his new book
which I had the honor to write the
forward for and publish and he's going
to discuss this book and the lessons he
learned from his incredible experiences
General thank you for joining us once
again well jao and eeko thank you so
much it's it's great to be with you
again and
especially uh the fact that uh Joo you
wrote the forward to this book in which
you uh quote Colonel hackworth so
anybody who has any knowledge of
leadership in terms of famous people to
have the forward mention that I have
some redeeming qualities in the eyes of
both Colonel hackworth and you uh it
doesn't get any better than that so I I
am just so honored to be on the podcast
again thank you well thank you for
coming back and and like I said it was
an honor for me to be able to write the
the forward and just to be able to read
through the book get an advanced copy of
the book hear all the stories and
lessons that you learned and for you for
you to have sat down and captured all
these lessons for people to hear the
story to hear what you've been through
your trials your tribulations it's just
a a fantastic book not just about
history but also about just how to live
a better life so thank you so much for
writing it and like I said it's my honor
to be able to write the forward um I
guess we might as well just get into it
a little bit um and start off from the
beginning from where you came from shy
town do you guys call it Shy town for
real no okay only Outsiders call it Shy
town
yeah all right let me just jump into the
book a little bit you say growing up in
the late 1940s and throughout the 1950s
in the Northwest side of the city of
Chicago was like winning the American
Lottery my Nuclear three generation
family lived in a tenement apartment in
the heart of an imig immigrant Community
while my parents owned and operated a
mom and pop gift shop on Main Street the
Logan Square neighborhood was truly an
American environment as it was primarily
immigrants polish German Italian Jewish
and one Asian family mine the
mukas so did you stand out much well you
know I uh obviously because I was the
only Asian uh perhaps I did but I never
felt that way I mean you know the
neighborhoods in Chicago the people who
live there
were a community regardless of your
ethnic background my best friend was
Jewish I had Catholic friends I happened
to be raised
Protestant uh but every neighborhood had
a a basic core which was your local
grocery store your Barber Shop your
local
bar and which was the most important a
church I mean Chicago has so so many you
know parishes Catholic parishes
Protestant churches uh uh Jewish temples
uh but the so I went I was born and
raised as I said in Logan Square
Northwest side of
Chicago and I went to we went to a
Methodist Church right up the street
literally it's on the same same street
maybe two blocks away and every
Sunday we would put on our Sunday best
clothes that's what you used to do in
those days and we would walk to church
as a family and that was other than
school that that really was I shouldn't
say other than it was the center of my
life at that time because you know every
Sunday we go I join the choir I I really
was a choir
boy and and I I actually in grammar
school I sang a solo on local WGN
TV with our youth choir U but I was in
Cub Scouts I was in Boy Scouts the the
pack and the troop were sponsored by our
church I mean the church was so
important and that led me to you know
the motto of the Boy Scouts for God in
country um and so that that was the
found part of the foundation of my life
so so you talk about your your mom and
your dad so your your dad was do you say
eay is that how you say it eay your dad
was eay but your mom was niss can you
explain the difference between eay and N
sure the the Japanese word for
generation is say okay and to count in
Japanese one two and three one is
ichy two is KN and three is son so so
Ichi
Nan e say is a combination of ichi and
say which means the first
generation to come to America so those
were the immigrants who were born in
Japan but they came to America the
second generation keeping in mind n is
too nissay were the first generation to
be born here so they were American
citizens Okay the third generation was
sansi now the immigration pattern for
the United for the Japanese to America
was an
anthropologist dream because they all
came here at the beginning it was a wave
from Hawaii and from Japan in about the
late 1800s early 1900s maybe a two
decade period of time where they came in
but then then by the 1920s or so there
was uh anti-japanese feelings already
mounting yellow per uh uh journalism uh
by the West Coast papers the Hurst
newspaper chain and they ran stories
about how you know the the Japanese
immigrants were uh doing terrible things
to white children or white women and so
there was a lot of and but what happened
was it was more than that these Japanese
immigrants were extremely
industrious I mean they worked hard and
they
saved and they were able to change a lot
of the here in California a lot of the
farmlands and Orchards were developed by
Japanese before the war before World War
I and uh you know there was jealousy
about that now what most people don't
know is that Japanese Nationals were
prohibited from owning
land in the United States okay but the
Japanese were smart what they did is
they purchased land in the name of their
children because they were citizens so
they could they could do that and but
there was a lot of jealousy so when the
war broke out it was very clear that the
Hysteria
from Pearl Harbor and by the way I
should point out that the
FBI checked on the Loyalty of Japanese
Americans you know that was one of the
reasons they were put in camps because
they said there was be a fifth colum
movement where they would be spying for
the Japanese and they would be pointing
out the weaknesses in our defense you
know our our Forts and so there was not
one case
of nissay or
eay of Espionage ever proven against
them w wow um so your dad was eay and he
he had come over yeah sorry I I kind
it's all good but then your mom was born
here yes and that was that was kind of a
cool story she she was well let me get
back to my dad first the reason he came
here he was born in Japan in
1900 and his
father uh kind of uh I wouldn't say
squandered he he he came from a
relatively well-to-do family in rural
Japan we were from a place called
yamanashi which is a prefecture in Japan
right near Mount Fuji okay in fact my
name
mukoyama muko means over there and Yama
means Mountain from my father's backyard
every day he could see Mount Fuji I mean
it was you know really beautiful and so
when people ask me what does your name
mean you know in English well having
been an English
major rather than saying you know the
mountain over there I say Yonder
Mountain and so anyway my my
grandfather invested I guess in the
Japanese future Market or something like
that for sake I think and he he lost
like half of the family fortune or you
know assets still he still had a decent
amount but so
1901 he books to to the United States
and the idea was to make enough money to
come back you know with honor back to to
Japan right so my father's born in 1900
190 one his father leaves stays in the
states for 18
years leaving by the way his wife with
five kids right and so when my father
turned
18 my grandmother said you get on a ship
and you go to States and you get you
know your father to come back so that's
what he did he he he got on a boat
landed in Seattle and my my grandfather
was in uh
uh Kerney
Nebraska and he was the head he was a
pretty sharp guy and he was the head of
a Japanese labor group working in the
sugar fields and uh very successful and
so my father said you know I'm on a
mission you know Mom says you got to go
back and so they moved to Denver
Colorado okay the real neat thing about
this was my grandfather was a Christian
this was highly highly unusual for a
Japanese at that time when did he become
a Christian I don't know because I never
met him he died before I you know came
of age in Japan cuz my father was
successful he did get him to go back but
but the a neat story was when they moved
to Denver my grandfather purchased a
boarding house okay and the boarding
house was at the end of a kind of a rail
line where miners used to you know go to
The Boarding House you know they'd work
in the mines and then they'd come well
the boarding house had like waitresses
you know it was a so they had a a a
restaurant or a whatever you want to
call it where they fed the miners but
the and they had waitresses you know
that would would wait on them well the
waitresses turn out to be more than
waitresses but my but my grandfather
didn't know that when he bought the
place right so being a
Christian he comes in and he closes down
that part of the so-called operations
right needless to say a lot of the
miners stopped coming and so so you know
but my my grandfather you know had had
enough money so my father said you know
it's time to go back and he went back
you know and and but my father said I'm
staying and and he he was very unusual
for eay most eay are were very uh they
came from rural
areas uh they weren't Highly Educated uh
and they were introverts because they
were learning a new culture they didn't
know the language my dad wasn't like
that at all he here he is he's 19 now
and he's in
California and he he sells cars he sells
insurance he he worked as a a as a house
boy for a millionaire somewhere uh he
was a
chauffeur uh he was a Gandy Man On The
Railroad and then he worked his way down
into Mexico he lived in Mexico for about
five six years and then he worked his
way up the Mississippi River Valley and
wound up in Chicago in the late 20s so
this is the kind of guy he was you know
he's a bachelor this whole time right
now my mother the way he met my mom was
she was born in Madison Wisconsin okay
and uh they had they had like a small
farm and uh and I don't what drove my
grandfather to do this but right at the
beginning of the
depression he moves the family to
Oklahoma you know the Dust
Bowl and sure enough she lives through
all she readed Pearl Buck you know and
she she said she nailed it you know
that's that was what they went through
you know and uh so she's she lived
through the depression and all that and
so now comes my father right he's in
Chicago somebody knew her family in
Oklahoma and introduced you know
introduced them because in those days
there were anti- uh
interracial laws in the United States
you know whites weren't supposed to
marry Asians and vice versa so so he
goes to see her and you know you think
in especially in those days they had
arranged marriages where was kind of a
given you know that well my mom was born
here she was having nothing of that you
know and he had to you know he had to
you know earn earn her approval which he
did thank goodness otherwise I wouldn't
be here and uh they got married moved to
Chicago and we were one of the few
Japanese American families in Chicago
before the war there were probably 3 to
400 total uh during after the war
because of the camps and the
relocation of Japanese Americans who are
in those concentration camps uh and by
the way they were not death camps but
they were concentration camps your
normal definition
of concentrating people of a certain
race or ethnicity behind barb wire with
machine guns facing in not facing out
and so when when they came back after
the war out out of the
camps and actually during the end of the
war there were so many jobs in Chicago
there was a good place to come but there
was no organization set up to do that so
my father and my uncle and some of the
eay who were in Chicago formed a what
was called a mutual Aid
Society um so when people came out of
Camp they would get them Apartments they
would find them jobs they get their kids
in school you know that type of thing
and you know you talk about in the book
that you're mom and dad basically
operated the the main gift shop in town
so you learned about hard work you
worked in there your mom worked 6 days a
week I think your dad worked seven days
a week like that was kind of the
American uh where you got a lot of your
American hard work values from watching
them yeah it it was a that was a
nice you
know I never felt
poor you know I we you know we never
owned a home we always lived in an
apartment building until you know I was
maybe 20 years old but I was already out
of home and and uh
and we our strength was our family and
our culture and our values and and uh
the gift shop was how uh you know we
were my father was able to pay for our
living really there was not enough money
for college for my brother or I and we
knew that but that was our lot in life
we didn't we didn't complain about it we
said okay we got to go out and earn it
you know just like my father was earning
you know and he he gave me a great gift
uh
about values when one of one of the
Japanese values which I as you know talk
about in the book is something called on
which means debt so when when people do
things for you in life you you remember
that you do not forget it and so my
father owned this gift shop for about 30
years it was a small gift shop on
Milwaukee Avenue in Chicago uh you know
they sold things like figurines and
lamps and ashtrays and dishes and you
know small things like that and uh it
was open 6 days a week uh on Monday and
Thursday nights until 9:00 the other
days were 9 to5 and it was just our
family who was running it we did have
one employee who was one of our
neighbors you know and that was it so
you know my brother and I would go to
the gift shop we'd help unpack things
line things up uh and then when we got
old enough to drive we would deliver CU
we had one of our things was free
delivery was kind of cool you guys were
the early version of Amazon
huh yeah you say here in the book
um my father inculcated the value of
Japanese culture into my brother and me
my parents demonstrated the core
cultural tenants through How They
Carried themselves and lived their lives
they instilled the concepts of Honor
loyalty dedication debt which you just
mentioned and perseverance and you use
the Japanese words in here which I'm not
going to pronounce because I'll mess him
up yeah and by the way Japanese I I I
know enough Japanese to be dangerous
okay which which our our parents did not
teach us Japanese when we were younger
because there there were really two
reasons number one is they would be able
to talk to themselves in Japanese and we
couldn't understand what they were
saying anybody who's a parent would love
to have that type of a thing uh but the
other thing was my brother's older than
I he he's six and a half seven years
older so he was a young boy during the
war when Pearl Harbor hit and everything
okay it wasn't the latest craze to go
around speaking Japanese at that time so
they didn't teach us uh Japanese so the
only Japanese that I really know believe
it or not I learned at the University of
Illinois and I I studied my Heritage
right because see when I went to
UI I was going to be an officer in the
United States Army uh initially I wanted
to I wanted to be a
chaplain I was so I because my faith is
Paramount in my life and as a
youth uh I was very active in our youth
activities and I wanted to become a
minister but I was also in Junior
ROTC and I Lov the milit and I know
we'll talk about this but the samurai
tradition is is huge in the Japanese
culture in the Japanese culture the
warrior is at the top of the culture
unlike the Chinese culture where where
the uh the academic is the The Scholar
is at the top of the culture okay but in
the Japanese culture it's the warrior
the samurai and so you know those two
things uh I I decided I was going to
join the Army and I was going to be a
chaplain that's how I was because I I
didn't know what God wanted me to do
well that didn't turn out uh and and I
decided to do the Army thing and I'm a
fairly focused guy so once I decide to
do something I I pretty well when I went
to I would when I would went to
University if it smelled look like or
move like military I was
in Yeah Yeah you mentioned in the book
that these Japanese cultural Concepts
were part of the Samurai tradition of
Bushido the way of the warrior Bushido
is the moral code that guides Samurai's
way of life so you had that being kind
of uh programmed into your brain and
then of course you had the church and
the neighborhood and then the American
values um and you say this as the result
of these two major cultural influence
the Eastern from my father and the
Western from my mother my Early
Childhood through my adolescent years
embodied the American immigrant
experience I shared this experience with
millions of other American families
although we must come to terms with our
government's mistakes this country has
provided my family and I with boundless
opportunities I've been blessed to be a
citizen of the greatest land of freedom
and opportunity in the world with pride
in my family's past and ancestry as my
father emphasized and exemplified we
should take pride in our ethnic heritage
but our future efforts must be dedicated
to the country of our citizenship the
United States of
America so yeah you were you you you
definitely did a great job somehow of
amalgamating all these different
influences from the Boy Scouts to the
church to the Bushido to the culture
from the Japanese side like this is you
turned out pretty good putting all that
stuff together well I as as I say i'
I've been so blessed and I have so many
people you know God puts people and
experiences in your life just when you
need them and you know I was when I was
in the Army I was blessed to have great
ncos who made me look good and I had
commanders who mentored me didn't cut my
head off when I screwed up and I had my
fair share of mistakes and uh I I just
had other other people in my private
life who came at the right
time my wife being one of them and uh
that's a God thing alone in fact in the
book I I talk a lot of what I refer to
as God things y I was going to say
that's an underlying theme in the book
is the the god things yeah well it just
you know perfect example is my wife my
wife is
Korean I'm from a Japanese Heritage
anybody who Stu studied history will
know that the odds of a Japanese guy
marrying a Korean woman on a scale of 1
to 100 is a minus
50 and yet God put us
together in an incredible way a very
short period of time of courtship and uh
she was here believe it or not in
California I'm in Chicago now get this
great catch that she got right I I had
come back from Vietnam I was unemployed
I'm living with my parents not in the
basement but I was I was living with my
parents right I don't have a job I'm in
Chicago you know she is in San Jose
California beautiful with uh it's
sponsored by an American family a very
welltoo American family in fact when I
went to pick her up on her first date I
pull up to the front of the house and
there is a fountain oh in front of house
say no more and so I say to myself self
what did you get yourself into here but
somehow I was able to convince her that
I had some kind of redeeming quality so
she fell for it and I tell people I'm
not I've not been a Salesman in my life
but that was the best sales job I ever
did you as your you you started to
mention this before but you had these
basically two gravitational forces that
were pulling you one of them was towards
the church and one of them was towards
the military there's a nice happy medium
there and that is become a chaplain
right which seems like a pretty good
move you know if you want to go with
your faith and with the military but you
it sounds like the the the church that
you were involved with started kind of
getting away from your beliefs yeah what
what happened was the the reason I and I
had this all planned I'm I'm I'm pretty
good on when I set when I determine a
mission and then studying how to get
there you know and so I was going to be
a chaplain but I really love the the
Samarai stuff right so I said I know
what I'm going to do instead of what
most chaplain do which is they go to
university then they go to Seminary and
then they join the military and they get
a direct Commission as a Champlain okay
I wasn't going to do that I was going to
go to university go through
rooc go through infantry training and
get qualified as an infantry Soldier go
to Airborne School Rangers school if I
could which eventually I couldn't but uh
you know I was going to be you know an
infantry officer and then I would go to
Seminary okay but by
I felt that by taking the same training
as my soldiers that I was shepherding
that I could be more effective and plus
they give me some street cred you know
with the soldiers if I walked in their
boots you know nobody gave me a break
when I went through my training I mean
you know the obstacle course you know at
5'4 and A2 uh you know I didn't nobody
gave me a break I didn't ask for one
because if I couldn't cut it I shouldn't
be there right
you know and so uh that was my plan okay
then what happened was my denomination
mer I'm Protestant my denomination
merged with another
denomination and they they had some
doctrine that I just didn't agree with
so now I was in a catch 22 because in
order to become a chaplain in the
military you have to be endorsed by your
denomination I wasn't buying
the theology or doctrine so I couldn't I
wasn't going to go to the Seminary when
I I really my heart wasn't in it it it
would be so hypocritical and I I just
couldn't do that so when I'm praying at
that time to God you know the the answer
I thought he was saying was no you know
and but that's not what it was it was
wait just wait yeah he was saying for
now infantry right it was divine
intervention send you to be an an
infantry men that's right that's exactly
right uh so you did you did this through
the ROC program at at what school was it
a University of Illinois and you're in
the ROC you actually end up staying
longer and get your master's degree
because you got your original degree in
English right and then you stayed and
got your master's degree right that's
right what happened was you know as I
said I didn't have I didn't have enough
money my parents couldn't find our
education right so you know as a
teenager I got a summer job as soon as I
could uh my senior year in high school I
worked at a warehouse in
Chicago Monday through Friday 5 p.m. to
p.m. and Saturdays 8 hours okay so 33
hours a week my senior year in high
school just so I could earn money so I
could go to college I still had to take
out a couple loans but at least it gave
me enough where I could do that and so
I'm I'm at the University of uh Illinois
by the way my first two years were at
the University of Illinois in
Chicago which was at Navy Pier okay most
people don't know that after the Korean
War the University of Illinois was going
to
expand and and into into
Chicago uh but it would take time you
know to to build find a place where to
put it and everything so so-called
temporarily it was at Navy Pier and so
it was It was kind of fun because we
used to joke about Harvard on the rocks
and and the only school that could be
torpedoed and and by the way the pier
was 58 of a mile long I know that
because the men's gym was on one side
and a lot of my classes around the
opposite side so I had 58s of a mile to
go between classes you know you get what
10 minutes between classes and so uh but
it was a great education because they
knew the University was coming so a lot
of
phds agreed to teach even though it was
just freshman and Southmore students
okay I never had you ready for this a
graduate student teach me my first two
years they all had phds now that was
good news and bad news the good news was
you know they all had phds the bad news
was they all had phds the bar was so
high that the Dropout level was
two-thirds of the students dropped out
yeah um again I'm I'm reading some
highlights of the book the book has got
so many details and stories and lessons
in it's just awesome but I I I wanted to
uh read this section cuz well well I got
a kick out of it um so you're you're
basically at this point you're going to
become a you're going to get a regular
army commission which was a big deal
back then and you say I was on my way to
receiving an a regular army commission
but I had to get two waivers first there
was a height minimum of 5 feet 5 in and
I was only 5et 4 and a half inches I'm
proud of that half inch but I had to be
waved to account for the other missing
half so second I had to get a doctor's
letter vouching that my past operation
to remove the tumor on my head would not
be a physical impairment in combat so I
went to see my lifelong family physician
Dr Shapiro at the time Vietnam protests
Nationwide were ensuing with guys
burning their draft cards and booking
for Canada to avoid service I walked
into Dr Shapiro's office and said doc I
need a favor from you regarding the Army
before I could get another word out he
responded don't worry Jim I'll make sure
you don't have to serve a day needless
to say I immediately corrected that
misunderstanding and he wrote the waiver
justification I received my regular army
officer Commission in the Infantry
Branch when I graduated in June my Army
Career was on its way but I concluded
the answer to my dilemma Ministry may be
a no but the military was a hard yes so
while a bunch of other people in the
country were trying to avoid going in
the Army and going to Vietnam you were
in there to get a waiver so you could go
oh yeah it was but you know in those
days that that was what most guys felt
like doing uh they felt you know because
our parents were the World War II
generation and they had served you know
you either had a father or uncle or
grandfather or cousin somebody who had
served and that
service value was inculcated in our in
my cohort generation and unfortunately
it was also the beginning of of uh you
know the 60s where you you had it
starting to go the other direction and
people were just you know booking the
Canada uh you know doing things so they
couldn't they wouldn't have to be they
wouldn't be able to
perform as and so they couldn't pass the
physical yeah you have this one section
here that I also wanted to mention um
it's I'm going to fast forward a little
bit you say I always saw an understood
life
not as filled with obstacles to overcome
but rather opportunities to excel there
is a phrase in Japanese she got ghai did
I say that right that's right you said
it right yeah which means it can't be
helped or it is what it is I neither
expected nor was I promised that life
was going to be a Rose Garden I had to
plant and cultivate the seeds of
opportunity if I wanted my future to
Blossom so I I I just thought thought
that that was a a good attitude
adjustment for anybody like hey this is
what you're going to get it's not going
to be perfect it's not going to be a
rose garden and That's the Way It Is
Well it that also holds true for my
faith uh I am a Christian I I uh make no
excuses for that in fact I'm very
blessed
and I tell I tell people especially
younger people that if you if you become
a Christian or a person of Faith there
is evil in this world and there is a guy
called Satan and you can deny it all you
want but the fact of the matter is that
if you are a person of Faith you're
going to be attacked you have to
understand that we are in spiritual
warfare every day every moment of every
day and we need to cling to our
values and our faith and that'll get you
through anything because uh God is
always with you he doesn't desert you I
when I was in combat I never worried
about my personal safety because I knew
if God was going to take me I'd be in a
better place so you know I I could then
concentrate on my main task which was my
soldiers mhm make sure we accomplished
our mission but with
professionalism and watching for my
Soldiers the hackworth was was a just a
master at that he never put us in a
position where we would be vulnerable
because of some crazy stupid order to do
X mhm he always found a way to you know
like
like my last operation and you know I it
was unusual uh my company in the Delta
we actually had a last operation because
President Nixon started withdrawing
units from Vietnam in
1969 and so my unit was one of the first
units that was selected so here I am a
company Commander infantry company
Commander we're out in the middle of
nowhere in the Delta and we had our
final mission come down and we were air
mobile so uh you know we were limited by
the number of Slicks or Huey helicopters
that we could get to go on on an
operation so that limited me as to how
many soldiers I could take okay so not
knowing how my my soldiers were going to
react to a quote unquote last
operation uh I had a certain number I
couldn't take everybody
I had more people who wanted to go that
I could take MH cuz I mean we were
hardcore that was the nickname of our
Battalion and we basically you know we
wanted the they wanted to be on that
last operation you know I mean I have my
machine gunner who had a broken thumb
okay now talk about a guy who could beg
off on an operation he he insisted on
going and he was my best machine gunner
and I said you're going
there's no question about it and so we
so we go on the operation the point I'm
trying to make here is I was extremely
careful I didn't now if something had
come up that I'd have to do I you know
we would have done it but nothing
unusual came up in during that operation
and when we came back uh there was
another company that was operating in
the same area the commander of that
company was and I talk about Ed than the
book was my roommate from the University
of Illinois so we were both in a
military honorary Society we were both
commissioned as infantry officers so can
you imagine how cool that was to in when
you're in a battalion and you are I I
commanded battle company and he
commanded Claymore company uh and by the
way that was one of hackworth's really
great things he used to he used to use
words to to motivate people so instead
of alpha bravo charlie delta you know
phonetic alphabet company designation he
had alert battle Claymore
dagger and so I commanded battle company
my my roommate Don Meyer uh commanded uh
Claymore company and so with that final
operation when we came back
I've got there's actually a photo not in
the book but there's a photo I have of
he and
I kind of sitting on the ground and
behind us are our soldiers right and
everybody's got a grin from ear to ear
because we had come back from the last
operation these guys were getting on
held you know they were going to go on a
Navy ship and go back to the States you
know yeah uh I decided not to go back
and and the company ready for this they
they went back to scoffield Barracks
Hawaii I could have I could have taken
my company back to Hawaii but I said no
you I'd only been there five months five
six months and I said no I got to I got
to do the full tour because I Was A
Bachelor I didn't know my wife at the
time uh I had friends classmates of mine
who had been killed there who some guys
were married going back for their second
or third tours and I said no it's not
right and you know I'm so I called
hackworth and he had already moved up to
the central Highlands as an advisor for
the Vietnamese at a very high two core
level and I contacted him I said sir you
know I'm by the way my nickname moo came
from hackworth because he couldn't
pronounce Muk oyamo and I called him sir
so uh he but anyway I so I contact him I
said I'm you know I'm not going with
back with the company you know could you
use me I had orders the next
day yeah you know it's interesting as
you talk about the last operation I was
always nervous about the last operation
so I never had one I never had one I
would only and I would do this with my
guys too I wouldn't say hey this is our
last operation or anything like that we
would just do operations and then on you
know I'd say all right that's it like
okay we could get what no we're not do
okay that was it the last the last
operation we did was the last one we
just did so no one would really know it
going into it even me even I wouldn't
know now I'd be might getting a little
bit sus suspect but I never wanted to
say this is going to be our last
operation because I don't know in my
mind I felt there was some kind of jinx
to it kind of like what you felt like
not wanting to do anything you know so
really to know something was your last
operation look when we were getting to
the end of deployment guys knew that
they had to be getting close but I never
talked about it just cuz I thought that
it was I I felt like superstitious about
it like it was a jinx to say this is our
last operation everyone stay safe it
seems like guys would uh get a little
bit nervous or try and be too safe and
sometimes when you're trying to be safe
you actually make yourself more at risk
because you're not being aggressive
which is a better way to stay alive
absolutely now
regarding that this Vietnam was
different when it came to end of a
deployment uh
because we did not towards the middle of
the war towards and towards the end our
rotations were not unit rotations they
were individual
Replacements and so uh that really hurt
the reintegration when they came when we
came back to the States believe it or
not one day we're in Vietnam the next
day we're in San Francisco by yourself
yes yeah yeah that that definitely is
identified as one of the problems you
know in World War II all those guys that
fought in the Pacific or fought in
Europe they all gotten a ship together
and sailed home at the end of the war
they got to talk they got to debrief
right guys in Vietnam by themselves they
leave their unit which they feel bad
about and then they come back to the
United States States alone and they get
dropped into Main Street USA without any
debrief without you know uh discussing
what they've been through with their
other people that could understand it so
yeah that definitely was not a good
system and I think you know if you're in
a platoon or you're in a company or
you're in a battalion everyone is on
everyone has a different mindset because
it might be my last mission might be
today but it might be your first mission
so and then it might be echo's you know
he's in the middle of deployment you got
a bunch of people with a bunch of
different mindsets and yeah that
definitely is and different levels of
experience so we might go out on a
mission it's my first mission you've
been here for six months I'm not as
skilled as you are I don't have the
knowledge that you have so we go out to
do a very complex Mission you're having
no problem with it but I don't know what
the heck is going on so yeah I
definitely like the way the military has
been doing it for the last Wars which is
yes you all deploy together unit but I
don't think you'll ever get a
better uh combination that they had in
World War II which is we're going to
deploy and we'll all go home when we all
win yes you know that that's a level of
commitment which I think is good because
I think when you're if you're going to
go to war you should have the commitment
of everyone in America saying yes when I
go or when my son goes they're not
coming home until
it's one and so do we really want to do
this because people think oh it's only
six months it's only one year I'll go
over come
back that's how politicians say oh we'll
go ahead and go over there no I can tell
my constituents it's only a one-year
deployment for their sons it's like how
about you tell your constituents well
number one your sons may die and number
two they're going to be over there until
we win which could take six years and
then all of a sudden you think well how
bad do we need to fight this war yes cuz
our politicians often just want to jump
in anym you know they're like your
friend at the bar that is you know wants
to pick fights with everybody but they
know that you're going to back them up
as soon as you leave the bar all of a
sudden they're the friendliest person in
the
world
um let me rewind a little bit on the
book here uh in November 1966 I was an
infantry school second lieutenant or
sorry as an infantry second Lieutenant
ready to fly overseas the next morning
and join the second Infantry Division on
the demilitarizing Zone in the Republic
of
Korea so this is you know right after
you got done with school you end up
going to Korea which Korea at this time
what year is this like
1964 66 66 yeah this was interesting
there's still combat operations taking
place in 1966 in Korea with including
people being wounded and killed during
that time frame oh yes absolutely uh and
this this was I I've actually you know
because I was I was the young stud
infantry guy you know just graduating
from from my basic officer training I
volunteer for Vietnam right and keep in
mind I'm a regular army officer normally
you know one of the so-called benefits
of being regular army is that you you uh
the Army gives you most of the time
preferential treatment on assignments
you know well I thought Vietnam was a
no-brainer I mean I'm an infantry guy we
got a war going on you know I want to go
there they sent me to Korea okay once
again this was a God thing because they
sent me to Korea but on the DMZ in Korea
see now we have the United States uh has
part of the DMZ which is the 38th
parallel that separates North Korea from
South Korea it's about a two 4,000 meter
band and it's a no man's land nobody's
supposed to be there and if you find
anybody in there you can you can it's
it's you can shoot the kill you know and
uh the North Korean Special
Forces used to try to infiltrate through
the DMZ to to get into South Korea to
attack
uh you know power plants uh disrupt the
government assassinate the president in
in the blue house which is our
equivalent of our White House and so we
were there to number one to to uh
reinforce that barrier but frankly we
were a trip
wire we were United States forces online
that if they came through and killed us
or attacked us then we would be at War
yeah with them and so we knew that we
you know we knew what we were up against
but uh so we did have these special
forces guys come through uh 13 months I
was there we had 12 guys killed and
about 40
wounded uh my first experience with mass
casualties was uh one of our compounds
had a sapper attack and you know because
these are special ops Guys these weren't
these are not guys who wanted to be
detected they wanted to get in do their
jobs and disappear which they were very
good at and so they they attacked one of
our camps on in the DMZ area and they
blew up a couple barracks and and so
that's the first time I had seen our
medics in action which you know next to
infantry the W's or military
occupational Specialties that I admire
the most are the Medics and in Vietnam
the helicopter Pilots yeah these guys
were incredible I mean they just you
know so to see 18 19y old Medics having
the triage and to make life decisions
about who lives and who dies you know
lining up wounded and and there they are
cuz see in the DM Z we were not
permitted to have
helicopters and so we couldn't metac
them they actually had to be ambulances
like in Mash you know you saw the MH
that's what we had and and they were not
uh paved roads these were all gravel
roads and everything and so here I get
to I get to
the I get to the scene of the situation
and and here these young Medics just you
know doing their
jobs yeah that's yeah you right about
that experience in the book and it's
definitely unsettling and and it's again
it's important for people to remember
that even in 1966 you still had soldiers
getting killed and wounded over there
and like you said you know the you talk
about the Medics just by their sheer
presence they're providing life-saving
medical and psych psychological Aid
despite the immense pressure of holding
someone's life in their hands they
perform with composure they are among
the most courageous soldiers on the
battlefield and actually I've had a
quite a few helicopter Pilots here from
Vietnam and one statistic that I don't
think I'll ever forget is there was
5,000 huis sent to Vietnam 3,200 of them
were lost in combat that's like
completely crazy to think about
especially when you think about today's
you know when an American Helicopter get
shot down
today it's like uh I mean they make
Blackhawk Down is make they write books
and might write and make movies about
those
situations in Vietnam that was just
another day they just just another day
would they'd get they' scrap that
helicopter and they'd go get another one
and get right back in it and fly it out
there and do it again and those it was
cool talking to those guys too like
those
helicopters they were kind of like a
muscle car like a 1960s muscle car it
was just like an
engine and a a prop on top and that's it
you know like there wasn't all these
Electronics in there so it wasn't
armored either no definitely not armored
it was just like like just a car just a
muscle car up there with a big engine in
it and and some propellers on top and
you're going to fly that thing in there
get shot up and get that thing out of
there it was those guys were definitely
uh incredibly
courageous um you there's another
another chapter in here which I
mentioned earlier you say you talk about
this uh when you were a student there
was a book called The Ugly American and
it talked about how Americans act when
we're overseas and you say I vowed to
myself I would do all I could to reverse
that Trend when I went abroad this
attitude was not rocket science I just
treated everyone I met with respect as
fellow humans I always tried to remember
that I was a guest in their country so I
treated them like I would want tourists
to treat me in America so you end up um
you're in this town you're you're on the
outskirts of this town Chang Pari am I
saying that right yeah Chang Peri Chang
Peri residents were extremely poor and
many Community Social Services were
lacking through my conversations with
the Korean populace I understood how
dire their needs were as a battalion
agitant who was responsible for unit
Administration and resources I saw an
opportunity to fill the Gap in the local
community the community had countless
needs so how could we make a difference
I established the Chang Chang Peri
community Assistance fund to affect a
broad base of change our fund was going
to be run by non-commission officers so
I appointed the Battalion command
sergeant major to be the chairman and
first sergeants to be the directors and
this is what you did you went out and
built you know helped them in a bunch of
different ways and just built a good
relationship with the people out in the
community yeah I was you know this this
was the beginning of my connection
lifelong connection with
Korea which which obviously was
culminated when I married my wife who
happens to be Korean uh so this was kind
of the the primer for me uh so I'm in
I'm in Korea I'm a platoon leader of a
weapons platoon company on the
DMZ and you know I've only been in
country four months or something and the
Battalion Commander calls me down to the
Battalion headquarters oops you know I'm
a I'm a young first lieutenant now and
I'm as so I go down to the Battalion
headquarters and he said Lieutenant
mukama how you doing and I said sir I'm
now after 11 years of training to be an
infantry officer have the honor to
command soldiers on the DMZ combat
patrolling and I said I'm having the
time of my life and
I'm really enjoying it and he said I
noticed you have a degree in
English and I said um yes sir and he
said I notice you have a master's
degree so I could see where this is
going right and I said yes sir and he
said how would you like to be the
Battalion adjudant now this was a
captain's position right and I'm I'm a
first lieutenant you know and I and but
I told him I I said sir you know I'm
honored that you would you know even
consider me but I'm really happy you
know leading
soldiers his response was Lieutenant I'm
not looking for happiness in my
Battalion he said you will report on
Monday yes sir I saluted and about face
and on Monday I was there and so but
what that H what that helped me with was
I was say I was in a position as the
Battalion
adjudant I knew all the Personnel
records of my soldiers and I knew what
their civilian background was so uh yeah
we did establish the Cheree community
Assistance fund uh and that was kind of
neat you know in those days we used to
get paid in cash once once a month the
pay officer would be sitting at a table
with his 45 and a guard armed guard
behind him and he got all this cash and
each guy would come up you know salute
name you know whatever and the payroll
officer would now in Korea like in
Vietnam we didn't we weren't paid in US
Dollars we were paid in what we call
MPCs Military Payment
certificates but they were they were in
dollar denominations you know 50 cents
dollar $5 you know that that type of
thing and then every now and then what
they would do this is this was to com
combat the black market because US
dollars were very valuable and you know
compared to the local currency okay yeah
so they change to
MPCs and so and then every now and then
they would they would cancel the current
series of
MPCs so those would be worth less and
they would hand out new MPCs so anybody
who is dealing with those old ones in
the black market you know they'd be
worthless so so but you know so there's
a pay officer and he pays out well you
know how GIS are I mean American
soldiers Sailors Marines they you know
they're they're very generous people and
especially when their pockets are full
right so and so you had this pay table
with the pay officer and then right next
to the pay officer is like the laundry
boy the you know these different
organizations that they owed money to
right collecting money at the end of the
table I put a coffee uh coffee can and I
just had a label on it and said you know
Chang perie community Assistance fund so
you know guys would put in 50 cents or a
dollar well a battalion's 1300 soldiers
you know so it's a decent amount of
money and so we we were able to get that
money put together so we could do things
for the community we had for example in
the village they and by the way Chang
perie was the poorest part of Korea
because it was right near the
DMZ so if a war came they'd be the first
to go so the so the country did not
invest in
infrastructure uh there were no paved
roads there were only gravel roads
electricity was like 3 hour a day I mean
you know that's you know people were
still living in in literally houses with
dirt floors and Str you know thatch
roofs and uh so
basically uh there was a fire in the
village and two homes were destroyed and
so we just went to the families and we
gave them a grant of so much money and
we just said we know you know you're
hurting so you know here they had a
school a a uh they had two schools in
Chang Pere they had a private school for
the rich and then they had a public
school for everybody else the public
school uh keep in mind this is only uh
this is
6066 so less was about 15 years after
the end of the Korean War 13 years and
wood was very scarce in Korea because
they had burned a lot of it for fuel and
things and so this public school
had no chairs no desks they didn't have
blackboards okay and so we bought them
like 40 desks and chairs and three
blackboards uh you know for for the
school and we did other things too for a
local hospital a church uh Church needed
some construction so being the S1 the P
Personnel officer I knew the guys who
were Carpenters in my unit so I sent
them down to the church so they could
help you know work with the the church
doors and things like that uh because
wood was so scarce they used to build
houses or build buildings out of cement
blocks okay well in order to make cement
you need sand and we were right near the
imim
river uh and banks of the river had sand
right so so I got uh five ton trucks or
and maybe deuce and a half from our SNS
Battalion uh suppli for Battalion go
down to the
riverbank get the sand bring it up to
the church so they could mix the cement
so my soldiers used to joke about how I
could have run for mayor of Chang pie
and
won uh you get done with this um with
this tour in Korea and you endend up
filling out like a dream
sheet uh which meant hey this is where
you know where do you want to go next is
what they're asking you and of course
you are looking to go to Vietnam so you
you want say you want to either go to
Fort Brag or Fort Benning which are
these are the places which would likely
deploy you to
Vietnam um and you say but instead I was
assigned to the Army infantry recruit
Training Center at Fort Lewis Washington
near Tacoma the pattern of requested
assignment denials was continued you
mentioned earlier like so far you have
you're you're just not getting what you
want what you're not getting the jobs
you want to have in the Army you want to
go to Vietnam you end up in Korea you
want to be a platoon Commander they let
you do that for a little while but then
they make you the the agitant like they
they're just you wanted to go to Ranger
school no no Ranger school like it's
just that's kind of the the hand you're
being dealt um and you do mention this
you say while in was Korea while in
Korea I had also observed another
pattern that was chipping away at my
trust in Army leadership I noticed some
leaders were more interested in their
careers than the unit Mission or the
welfare of the troops and you mentioned
that there was like a ranking system and
some of the Battalion the Battalion
commanders got ranked and you looked at
the way that the Battalion commanders
were ranked and you would have ranked
them let's say 1 two 3 4 they ranked
them 43 21 so they actually from a
leadership perspective were the opposite
as you saw saw them which was you know
just a
little bit of a a scary thing to see
from your perspective as a young uh
Lieutenant yeah it the Insight it gave
me was that the
Army appeared to be more interested in
developing
managers than
commanders and uh it it was very clear
it was it was it was sad in a sense but
then it also started to chip away as I
said at
my my desire to spend the rest 20 30
years of my life you know with a system
that uh number one had was ignoring
everything that I I had ever asked for
you know they wouldn't even throw me a
bone right they you know make me a
little happy uh but also I saw what they
did with leadership and you know
hackworth was your you know perfect
example here's a guy who stood up you
know and and he was just you know you're
you're the nail sticking out and you get
pounded back down but he wouldn't stay
down
mhm uh you say this I had two roommates
during my tour at Fort Lewis the first
was Lieutenant Lieutenant first
lieutenant Donald IID id id yeah Don was
a fellow infantry officer in a
Washington state native Don got orders
to Vietnam and joined the 25th Infantry
25th ID Tropic lightning division he was
killed in action May
1969 on June 27th 1969 Life Magazine
published the photos of more than 200
soldiers who were killed in action in
just one week in Vietnam the week
selected was the week that Don died and
his photo was included this publication
became a rallying cry for the anti-war
move Mo movement Meanwhile my former
roommate from College Don lank Meyer had
just recovered from wounds sustained in
Vietnam and was looking for a new
assignment we had kept in touch and he
got orders to be assigned to the
training Cadre the training center at
Fort Lewis and you already mentioned Don
as well Don
Meyer uh you end up in this position as
the Secretary of general staff and so
you're working kind of directly um for
the
general
and you you say this I had the opport in
that position I had the opportunity to
meet one man who changed the course of
my career leadership and life Lieutenant
Colonel David hackworth reported into
Fort Lewis as a new Battalion Commander
I was the first officer he met at the
headquarters due to my SGS job I knew
who hackworth was a living infantry
Legend I had already read his
informative handbook on small unit
tactics and Guerilla Warfare but I tried
to conceal my excitement and followed
with Professional
Regulations I immediately stood up and
said welcome to Fort Lewis Lieutenant
Colonel hackworth the general will be
will be with you shortly hackworth as
all veterans will tell you arrived early
to guarantee he would not be late in
Practical military terms combat
operations have key times for a certain
actions to happen by all units in an
operation if one unit fails to do their
part at the time stated in the
operations order it could mean the
failure of the total operation resulting
in loss of life I've always followed
that policy of never being late perhaps
I would will admit to an extreme my
children used to complain about arriving
always early but I taught them that it
is disrespectful to the other person to
be late time is something precious that
you cannot give back to someone when you
are late without hesitation Colonel
hackworth responded to me what are you
doing sitting behind a desk if you want
a company I'll give it to you I answered
that I was honored but that I'd come to
the same conclusion weeks earlier and
had already secured a company command
from another Battalion Commander he was
not happy but I but understood I had
given my word and had to stick by it I
later learned that hackworth had an
uncanny knack for sizing people up
literally on the spot in his view you
were either a stud or a dud and there
was nothing in between thankfully he
quickly decided that I was a stud based
on my eager but respectful response I
observed this phenomenon for over 30
years and Lieutenant Colonel hackworth's
intuition was always accurate tough
training Cycles were necessary to
prepare our soldiers for the brutality
of Vietnam as it turned out my roommate
Don Meyer was already assigned to be a
company commander in the Battalion that
hackworth took over so I was debriefed
on his firsthand experiences hackworth
pushed his recruits harder than ever
before he rightfully maintained that we
were not doing our recruits any favors
by not pushing them to their limits in
training intense and harsh training
would pay benefits and save lives in
combat he was as always
spoton I had the same policy influenced
by my samurai teachings 99% of Fort
Lewis graduates were shipping to Vietnam
so no slack could be permitted in our
standards we were short training
officers in my Battalion so I was
leading my company with no officers but
I had great non-commissioned
officers so there's your introduction to
hackworth meeting him for the first time
yeah it was uh like I said he he just
had that that Knack but uh and he was
very accurate it was uncanny it was just
un and that's why he was so successful
because he surrounded
himself with really good people and
that's the first thing I noticed when I
got to Vietnam and I met the officers of
the Battalion I mean these guys were
were all extremely competent and uh I I
didn't see one that I wouldn't serve
with later mhm uh cuz he had he had
already called out the the people that
he didn't
want and he you know he that he just
wouldn't put up with with uh people who
you know he you could make a mistake
with him as long as you were giving your
best cuz we all make mistakes MH uh but
if he saw a slacker I mean that was it
gone he he he wasn't there to win the
hearts and minds of of people who are
not willing to pay attent especially in
combat you know you can't put up with
that yeah for sure uh you you tell a
story in here about how um one of
hackworth's drill sergeants had beat up
one of the trainee and you guys kind of
get together and you're able and it's a
great story from the book that's why get
the book so you can get the details of
this story but you guys figure out a way
to kind of get the problem resolved
still preserve the career of the drill
sergeant still keep the traine happy you
guys get creative in solving this
problem and and you say in the book
through this indirect approach to
problem solving I witnessed why Colonel
hackworth's leadership had become
legendary he understood how to adjust
tactics to resolve problems trained
subordinates to step up and above all
cared about the outcome for his troops
I was lucky that this wasn't the only
incident where I'd learned from his
leadership firsthand but it was just the
beginning this resolution cemented the
professional connection with Colonel
hackworth that would lead me to
eventually getting to
Vietnam so you were already slated in
what happened with the Battalion that
you were supposed to go
in so you said you were slated into a
battalion and when hackworth said hey
you should be in a you should be in a
company command and you said well I've
already I'm already supposed to be in
what happened with that one yeah no uh
that was a good Battalion I had a
excellent Battalion
Commander uh what and so he uh we were
short officers uh in the training units
at that time rightfully so because we
needed guys on you know in combat to
fight and I was we didn't have an
executive officer in our Battalion I was
the senior
company Commander Data rank so when the
Battalion Commander went on leave I
would be the acting Battalion Commander
okay and so that's when that incident
occurred with with uh hackers juel Sant
who now he was he was a a Vietnam
veteran Airborne guy you know an E7 a
real honest to goodness E7 and uh who
had been in combat and so but now he's a
drill sergeant one of hack wordss guys M
and our our two companies shared a
company Street at Fort Lewis and so my
his drill sergeant when his was in his
car and one of my recruits was walking
in in the company street with his hands
in his pocket not a good idea and which
we used to refer to them as Air Force
wor gloves but so he he stops his car
rolls down the window and tells the
recruit you know recruit take your hands
out of your pockets the recruit then
says something about the Sergeant's wife
or mother and so he gets out of his car
picks the guy up by his collar takes him
into a day room you know with you know
away so nobody can see what's going on
and he bounces him off the wall a couple
times to get his attention doesn't break
anything you know but trying to put the
fear of God in him there was one person
in that day room which was one of my
ncos okay but he was he was what they
called a a instant NCO in Vietnam we
became
short uh non-commission officers
especially the junior ones the
e5s and the e6s so they had a special
program where the best graduates out of
the advanced individual training would
stay for 90 days get further training
and they would graduate as
e5s okay and we used to call them shake
and bake ncos or instant ncos so that
that was one of the guy who's in the you
know day room right well my recruit Ro
was a he was a a trainee he was one of
so-called uh
uh a he he had enough knowledge of
uniform code of military Justice to be
dangerous okay so he said well you can't
do this you know I'm going to get you
Court Marshal because this is trainee
abuse you know which in those days in
the training I mean that was that was a
big deal right it's still kind of a big
deal now it's probably even more of a
big deal now well the good news was that
the drill sergeant and the trainee were
both black okay had had one been White
and the other black it would have been
even worse okay but so that was the good
news and so the NCO when when the when
my trainee said that well he just looks
at the other NCO and he says you don't
have a witness you know thinking that
NCO would back up you know good old NCO
Justice and you know and my NCO says I
saw the whole
thing uh oh so anyway that's and so I
get a call from the staff duty officer
because I'm the acting Battalion
Commander right I'm at home and I get
this call you know and one of our
trainees has been beaten up by you know
and mean so I said don't call Brigade I
said wait until I call you back I call
hackworth right away I said sir we have
a problem you know and he said well
let's meet you know at your headquarters
so we both went and got together and and
we we came up with a a plan and so I I
talk about in the book but a long story
short is this happened right before
Christmas okay and there was going to be
a
Christmas time leave time for the
trainees actually because they're
they're all going to Vietnam right so at
least give them time with their families
at you know Christmas time so they're
all kind of you know wanting to go there
right so hackworth and I bring the
trainee in but I'm the Battalion
Commander so Hacker's just sitting on
the side okay and and I said you know
tell me what happened you know and of
course the story is totally different
you know I was just innocent I was
walking in the company Street and this
Jo Sergeant for whatever reason took me
into a room and beat me up and you know
that was his story right so I'm sitting
there I say well we want Justice to be
done for you what do you want I want
this guy Court Marshal okay said okay we
could we could probably make that happen
uh I said uh um but you know you're to
for a court Marshal this is pretty
important stuff and uh you'll have to be
a material witness for this
and the trial will probably go on for a
little
while I'm I'm saying all this and I can
see the the kid is thinking to himself
uhoh I'm I'm not going to be able to go
home for Christmas right and hack with
you know buts in and he said well I
think I can help here you know I can do
uniform code of military Justice Article
15 non-judicial punishment and he list
all the major punishments you know oh
yeah yeah you know red and water for 30
days red exactly all that forfeiture of
pay you know and so he said but we want
Justice done for you I I now it's my
turn you know but we want Justice Done
For You trainee so what do you want and
he said well I'm I'm pretty confident in
Colonel hackworth I'm sure he could
handle this I said fine then we'll we'll
proceed that way without a court marshal
and I said you're dismissed now I wanted
to really go up one side and down the
other about his you know his part of
this deal but I didn't want to
jeopardize what we had just done you
know and so we bring in the Hackler
drill sergeant and and Hackler says okay
Article 15 you know we're going to take
a rank one rank away from you you know
uh months pay it's suspended for 90 days
and for those of us who have been in the
military all that means is for 90 days
if you keep your nose clean for 90 days
it goes away and so that's what we
did got it done took care of
everybody um I'm gonna fast forward a
little a bit to
Vietnam uh going to the book while I was
commanding a while I was commanding
battle company in his Battalion I earned
a Priceless honor from Colonel hackworth
he gave me my nickname in the military
he couldn't pronounce mukama so he
called me
moo I called him sir though he was
affectionately referred to as hack by
the troops hack had a great knack for
making our troops feel special by
creating names or modos only used by our
unit instead of the usual company
designations using the phonetic alphabet
of alpha bravo charlie delta our
companies became alert battle Claymore
and Dagger when he first took command of
the Battalion he changed the name of the
fire support base from fire support base
Dicky to FSB danger and most important
he named our Battalion the hardcore we
were also a Rondo unit which refers to
the lurs or longrange reconnaissance
patrols elite units also had military
greetings and responses unique to their
units when officers entered a unit this
was tremendous a tremendous builder of a
spree decor or unit Pride for for the
hardcore when an enlisted Soldier met an
officer they saluted and said hardcore
Rondo the officer would appropriately
respond no slack I actually saw
hack walk up to a wounded soldier on a
stretcher and the soldier would salute
and say hardcore Rondo sir these
nicknames served as a constant morale
boost in even in the toughest times
everyone was proud to be
hardcore and that's the uh the cover of
the book is a picture of you you're
standing on the cover and you've got
you're holding your helmet your uh
helicopter helmet and of course written
across the forehead of the helmet in
giant letters it says
hardcore when when we were discussing
the book that was the you know we
started talking about the cover of the
book and I was talking to John and I
said hey the the pictures that I would
like on the cover I mean obviously I'm
not the the last word but that picture
of of General the general with the with
the helmet that says hardcore and I said
it doesn't get much better than that in
my
book so um you also you know you
mentioned this earlier months that
hardships of combat I was also blessed
to have one of the greatest Spirit
brosters my camaraderie with my best
friend the good Lord provides people in
your life that provide a special Comfort
during the most difficult times as I
mentioned earlier my former roommate Don
Meyer was in RC program and was also
commissioned as an infantry officer out
of college after graduating Don joined
the 101st Airborne in Vietnam he was
wounded and recovered once we reunited
at Fort Lewis he became and became
roommates our friendship quickly
reinvigorated he then joined hackworth
with the hardcore and commanded Claymore
company then I joined the hardcore and
commanded battle
company yeah you know Don was uh don was
like
6'4 and and to review I was 5'4 and a
half yes sir and so so we would walk
around campus and it was it was like
well a lot of young people won't even
know who mutton Jeff was but uh we were
like mutton Jeff uh and we did you know
we both came from rather modest
backgrounds to say the least although he
did have a car and uh so uh we both
lived in the dorms cuz we couldn't
afford an apartment it was the cheapest
way to to live but the dorms didn't
serve dinner on Sundays okay so he and I
would go down to you know the uh the
local part of champagne or vanana at the
University of Illinois and there was a
Chinese restaurant so we go in there we
could only afford one order of shrimp
with lobster sauce and each of us got a
beer
okay and we would sit there literally
one shrimp for you one shrimp for me two
for you two for me we'd actually count
the shrimp and but you know we had good
times together and at at the University
and so to be with him in Vietnam it it
doesn't get any better than that oh yeah
for sure so you're a company Commander
what was your operational Tempo like
like how often was your company going
going out on operations when you were in
the hardcore oh we we go out
uh uh we' go out weekly uh three or four
days we didn't we didn't have long
operations hackworth
basically uh his theory now keep in mind
we were in the makong Delta we were not
fighting NVA we weren't fighting North
Vietnam Army regulars right we were
fighting guerillas who were
just as dedicated I might add I mean I
never I'll never forget the one
important battle we had I was in the
this the uh I was with hackworth who is
in in in his helicopter over this battle
and watching him this is a culmination
of of about a week and a half of
preparation we had gotten intelligence
that there was a Vietnamese really was a
training Battalion or a battal you know
of new recruits in our area and we had
intelligence about where we thought they
were at and
so uh hackworth could smell it a mile
away and he said this is this is Rock
Solid we we got to act on this so one
the night of one day he put in two
companies okay and then the next morning
he he put in the third and fourth
companies and we kind of
encircled this area and then he called
in artillery Naval
gunfire artillery you know gunships and
and it was like a turkey shoot it was
incredible I'm in the helicopter with
him CU I'd only been in country about a
month and and he wanted me to to learn
operations right and so I'm sitting
there and watching him the way I phrase
it orchestrate the
battlefield he knew where the companies
were he you know we had a map we're
flying over this whole thing right and
at the beginning before we even had
contact you know everybody's in position
and we got a a uh radio contact from our
one of our commanders and he said just
had a contact killed three
VC uh you know captured a couple weapons
they're
heading
Northwest okay so hacker sitting there
and he said
moo about 15 minutes we should hear from
Claymore okay 15
minutes Claymore comes up you know and
you know same thing contact we killed so
many and blah blah blah and then
and in the meantime he's still pouring
all this this uh ordinance in on the
area so they're trying to get out but
they're already en circled you know and
and this went on all day and in fact it
got
so uh it was and higher headquarters
found out what was happening you know
cuz all this traffic and and uh the
Brigade Commander comes now he's above
us right cir oh so he shows up actually
in his own helicopter oh yeah okay you
know
and and so then the division Commander I
mean this this was nuts you know and
Haworth gets on the on the line he said
listen you guys I'm calling in artillery
and calling in our air strikes I can't
worry about you so you know if you want
to meet me somewhere you know I can give
you a brief but get out of my
AO that's you know that's what he said
right so so division well I want you to
meet me at you know X okay
so and hackworth is really really upset
and and the S3 major uh mner uh he he
was in the helicopter with us you know
so hackworth lands a helicopter and then
puts murder and me in charge of what's
going on you know and we go back up and
we take our position and we're and so it
it was just uh just incredible but the
thing that the reason I brought this up
is I I started by saying the VC and how
dedicated they were okay I saw a a a VC
who is dying near a
canal okay he took his
AK-47 and he threw it in the
canal the reason for that
is during during Vietnam we had
unfortunately body counts MH where it
was you know they wanted us to report
how many we had killed and wounded and
then how many weapons we had captur well
the way you could get a credible body
count was that the number of weapons was
kind of close to the number of people
who had been killed but let's say you
say you know we kill 20 and we have two
weapons that's kind of you know the VC
knew that you know and they and by the
way they had AK-47s which were much
better weapons than our M16s you know
and when when I say that that you know
you could you could pick up an AK-47 out
of mud almost and fire it still going to
work yeah yeah so so I saw the
dedication of of the the VC I always
that's one
axom in combat is always respect your
enemy
me never underestimate
them did you have any do you remember
any major leadership challenges that you
had as a company
Commander I you know I really I really
can't think of it well I mean I I after
hackworth left he had a we had a new
battan Commander come in nobody could
fill hacker shoes and that had to be a
rough
come and take that was right so here I
am I'm now the company commander of
battle company and what we used to do is
we be out in the field all the companies
were not out at the same time you know
we'd rotate okay because one one company
might be uh Manning Manning the security
for the you know kind of a standown
situation all you're doing is you're you
know you're guarding the the uh
the perimeter and uh so you're out on
you're out on patrol and then you come
back you're out on operations and you
come back and you're supposed to get
like a break you know uh to recover
while the other companies go out well I
had a situation where my guys were being
sent right out again while other
companies could stay
longer that didn't fly with me so I went
to the Battalion commander in fact we
once again they used to joke about a
path between my my Hooch and the
Battalion Commander's hooch where i' go
and I'd say Hey listen you know sir just
want to remind you that we've been out
you know and these guys are still here
you know and they're staying and we have
to go out again I think uh maybe
somebody miss
something
uh you have a picture there's a picture
um that's kind of kind of famous it read
in when like the AP I guess whatever AP
was back in the day or UPI UPI that's
what it was um what was the what was
going on in that picture it's a famous
picture it's in the book what I know
that you didn't F you didn't never saw
the picture until year a few years later
right but when you saw that picture what
was going on in that picture it's I know
it's uh you mention in the book it's one
it's your radiomen um Barry rabinovitz
rabinovitz spec five right and and like
he's getting carried out on a stretcher
what's going on in that photograph yeah
what happened was that we we had uh in
in this particular operation which
wasn't a heavy
operation uh he basically detonated a
booby
trap and sucking chest wounds uh I was
near him so I got a little shrapnel but
it wasn't a big deal just scratches and
and and uh so we called a metac
helicopter there were some other guys
wounded too so uh there was a UPI
photographer on that
helicopter and he snapped a photo of my
guys carrying Barry on a
stretcher towards the
helicopter and uh it's a very
action-packed photo you could just see
the the expression on my guys carrying
you know of concern carrying his his uh
wounded body to the helicopter and then
in the background I'm standing there
watching all of this because I I have my
radio in my hand I just had called in
the helicopter and you see the all the
debris and smoke uh around it because in
Vietnam when you called in a meta
metac uh you would take a smoke grenade
and we had different colors
of smoke grenades so you could you would
say like let's say it's a yellow smoke
grenade so we're popping yellow you know
that's so the metac helicopter knew
that's where where to land and we had
secured that area you know so that's
what that photo is that the story behind
that photo was and as you said I didn't
know about that photo until about three
years later after ID come back from
Vietnam I was now working for a I I had
left the regular army which is part of
my book story but I left I left the
regular army and I joined the reserves
uh because I had a commitment frankly of
I was going to serve 20 years no matter
what turned out to be 32 but you know uh
but what happened was I was working for
a a Japanese Trading Company we were
importing bicycles and bicy IC Le parts
to Schwin bicycle in Chicago so I'm I'm
I'm paying a sales call on on the guys
at Schwin I'm in the you know the
waiting area you know they had a coffee
table with magazines and there's a US
News and World Report magazine and it
had an article about Vietnam so I said
hey I'll take a look at this kind of
interested and that photo was there but
it was only like 3 in by 3 in is you
know and it and so I looked at it and
then I I saw guys in who are in my
company so I knew it was our company and
then I saw I was in it so then I I wrote
uh the magazine I said how can I how can
I get a copy of this and and they said
it was UPI so I contacted UPI and
ironically this the uh photographer was
a
Japanese uh photographer and so it got
the photo but but the story is that was
selected as the UPI photo for the day
that kind of went around the world about
Vietnam because it was such an
action-packed photo and it got in Stars
and Stripes okay Pacific Stars and
Stripes uh which which as you know is is
the newspaper for service members
throughout the world Y and it was on uh
stars and stripes and so fast forward 50
years I'm now at a reunion of the
hardcore in Tampa Bay Florida right and
we're in this General Session and one of
the one of the guys one of the Infantry
soldiers raises his hand he says I've
got something for General moo okay so I
don't know what you know so I go go up
there and he said he had the Pacific
Stars and Stripes oh wow issue that he
had saved for 50 years
and he gave it to me because I you know
I was the company commander and I was I
was in it and I I said I can't take this
you know you saved this he said sir you
are you know you are the commander you
need to have this and as I say in the
book that just shows you the
bond between soldiers who have who have
fought together and the respect that we
have for each other MH that he would
give that up you know for me was just a
honor yeah no
doubt um you say this about hackworth as
you're wrapping up the uh his or as he's
starting to finish up his tour there
Colonel hackworth said an example every
time he stepped on the battlefield
meriting our respect and showing us how
much he cared I was a company commander
in a battalion he led in mayong Delta of
1969 uh colonel hackworth was a Korean
War veteran who was awarded his eighth
no that's not a Mis misprint Purple
Heart for wounds sustained in combat
while he was our commander while he was
monitoring a firefight in his C2
helicopter he noticed some of our
soldiers were in trouble and seriously
wounded he ordered his pilot to land the
chopper in the middle of the firefight
to extract and save the wounded soldiers
The Reluctant pilot needed some
convincing but eventually landed the
small CNC helicopter was able to load
the two wounded men but there was no
room for hackworth he ordered the pilot
to lift off with him standing on the
skids he got hit in the leg earning him
his eighth Purple Heart after that
incident hackworth could have ordered us
to walk through a wall of fire and we
simply would have asked where do you
want us to go by setting an example of
our selfless and fearless Warrior and
leader Colonel hackworth earned our
lasting trust and admiration that went
beyond the battlefield and into our
hearts leaders must set the example
physically mentally and ethically
now that um well going on going back to
another section of the book Colonel
hackworth had transferred to two cor to
become the senior operations officer or
G3 adviser after receiving his eighth
Purple Heart the Army took him out of
the field because they did not want the
enemy to gain a huge morale boost by
killing one of our greatest infantry men
of all time a month after hackworth was
transferred President Nixon started the
withdrawal of our infantry units from
Vietnam the hardcore was one of the
first to be selected when do you
remember the day that he actually left
the
Battalion yeah it was
uh we we really didn't have a big
ceremony I mean you know I mean there
was a change of command but it wasn't uh
you know we're out in the middle we're
in a fire support base I mean you know
it's going to be like five minutes it's
not going to be a band and you know and
all that stuff happening like you have
State Side yep but it it was very moving
for the guys cuz he had taken the
hardcore from this and I didn't maybe I
talked about a little bit when hackworth
was assigned to be that Battalion
Commander it was one of the worst
battalions in
Vietnam basically draft East you know he
had commanded a Balian of the
101st little
different quality of soldiers okay this
was an all this is basically a drafty
Battalion and uh I'll just say the
previous leadership was
not hackworth
standard and they they they were taking
casualties morale was
down uh hackworth gets there and he
turns it around a th% not 100% U to make
it one of the most efficient Fighting
Machines in in our our ratio of of kills
to our soldiers getting wounded or
killed was you know I I don't know what
it was but it it had to be like you know
80 to 20 or something if not
higher uh you say this I could have take
so that so your your Battalion gets
selected to go home basically we were
talking about this last mission thing
and and as you mentioned um you could
have gone back and right to scoffield
barracks in Hawaii uh you said but I was
a young stud lifer and had only been in
country five months so I decided to
return I contacted hackworth and asked
him if he could use me the next day I
had orders to report to military
assistance command Vietnam Team 25 where
hackworth was a member I was assigned
the hcore G3 plan advisor authorized as
a major so you just sent note hey you
got anything for me next day you got
orders to your new assignment in Vietnam
yeah uh you're in this advisor role and
you say in November 1969 I was assigned
to a company Deputy senior enlister
Deputy the deputy senior enlisted
adviser a full Colonel and the senior
enlisted advisor Sergeant Major Robert
dundo on an inspection trip of Special
Forces camps on the border of laon
Cambodia I was a young Captain coming
along to take notes when we landed on
the first camp we immediately came under
attack a rocket was shot Landing just 20
M away from me but woefully it hit the
senior enlisted adviser he was killed
the backstory was even more
gut-wrenching the sergeant major was
scheduled to go on RNR the following day
to Hawaii to meet his wife waiting to
celebrate their 25th weding anniversary
I being a captain outranked the sergeant
major I could have ordered him not to go
get on that helicopter but I didn't
I carried immense buried survival guilt
for decades combat was gruesome heart
rendering guilt-ridden my deployments in
Korea and Vietnam tested my leadership
bravery and Humanity but I also
witnessed men of Courage brothers and
leaders come together for our duty to
protect and serve the finest country in
the
world I've shared examples of the
uncertainty of being in combat one
cannot control what happened in the past
or what will occur in the future but we
can control what our reaction is in the
present as I entered back into the
civilian world and into my life's next
phases I always kept these lessons in
combat Warfare Lieutenant Colonel
hackworth leadership and God's Divine
timing close to my
heart yeah that's that's one of those
things where you know you look back and
of course what have showa Coulda and all
these little decisions that we make in
leadership
positions you know that one tiny
decision that you do or don't do and
you've made thousands of decisions like
that when you're in Vietnam you know you
make thousands of decisions like
that well you know this this uh I talk
about Survivor guilt which is related to
something that I've been very passionate
about so and I'm sure you were going to
talk about it but I I think this is a
good time and that has to do with the
invisible wounds of
War uh especially you know I go around
the country giving speeches about this
and I literally have been to medical
colleges I I've spoken at the American
Psychological Association uh uh District
19 which is the military
uh
psychologist and I've everybody knows
what PTSD is I mean you'd have to live
in a burrow not knowing what that is
people also know what traumatic brain
injury is okay especially Sports too and
then military sexual
trauma uh both male and
female so those are these are not
physical wounds but there're wounds that
are
internalized and but there's one that is
not spoken about very much and that is
moral
injury and
so when I talk about moral injury uh I I
asked for a show of hands you know how
many people are aware of PTSD every hand
goes up yeah how many are aware of you
know traumatic brain injury every hand
goes up how many are aware of moral
injury I might get a few hands go up but
but now actually to be fair in the last
couple years moral injury has
surfaced more into the discussion about
uh wounds of war and and that's because
of the high suicide rates and I am my
organization military Outreach
USA uh which is a faith-based
nonprofit uh to help
veterans we concentrate in two specific
areas because not you know there are
thousands literally thousands of
nonprofits out there wanting to help our
veterans uh so you can't be everything
to everyone and so our Niche is are one
homeless veterans and number two to
reducing the suicide
rate so when it comes to homeless
veterans uh we have uh we we had an
agreement signed by the Secretary of
Veterans Affairs in
2016 that recognized military Outreach
USA as an
organization that could we created a a
program called Veterans exiting
homelessness okay now you have to
understand military Outreach is a small
organization we're just handful of
volunteers uh very uh there's only two
people to get any pay and it's not a lot
like part-time pay is what I'm talking
about and uh we
basically uh have set up this program
for
veterans working with the
VA who are working with VA social
workers and they get them
stabilized where they can function and
get them into what they call permanent
housing which is really a one-bedroom
apartment that's subsidized by a HUD
Vash voucher okay they give them the
keys to the apartment but that's all
they give them so imagine the first time
you moved into an apartment you kind of
need stuff like Lysol toilet paper
towels sponges buckets uh how about a
bed right they don't have a bed they
might have a cardboard box or a sleeping
bag or a blanket so we worked with the
VA because as I said we're a small
organization there's no way for us to
vet these people and we know that there
are a lot of people out there who claim
to be veterans who are not veterans so
we don't have to deal with that because
the VA already qualifies these people as
veterans okay so we have a network of
houses of worship of all
faiths and we've expanded that Network
to include American Legion VFW Post uh
other vsos veteran service
organizations uh we have uh lions clubs
rotary you even have high schools and we
made a list of what we call move in
essential items these items that
somebody needs when they you know move
into an apartment and we said could you
kind of have a you know get your
congregations or parishes and make a
collection of this stuff or your high
schools and uh we'll arrange with you to
have it we'll we'll pick pick it up and
then the VA social workers will come and
take it away and they then give it
directly to the veterans now we don't
ever get in contact directly with the
veterans ourselves but that's okay I I
just want them to be helped okay and
since
2016 we've been able to raise over 1.3
million items
uh over $1 million worth of items and we
just delivered our
2,600
bed now these are people who are no
longer sleeping on the floors or streets
or whatever and uh so that's one program
veterans exiting homelessness the other
program is about moral injury and the
invisible wounds of War where I go out
and I actually
explain what it is but in
2015 so that's like eight year you know
eight years ago we published a book
military Outreach which is on our
website it's in a resource by the way
our website is military Outreach usa.org
military Outreach usa.org go on our
website
resources the name of the book is they
don't res receive purple
hearts and it's all about the invisible
wounds of War we talk about moral injury
uh moral injury is nothing
new uh if you read uh the ilad if you
read
Shakespeare you will read the Bible uh
The Book of Numbers chapter 31 when the
Jewish Warriors returned from defeating
the midianites Moses greets them outside
of the camp but he will not let them
re-enter until they go through a
purification process the knights when
they came back from the Crusades were
not permitted to participate in the Holy
sacraments until they went through
Penance and Reconciliation the Native
American Indians have had sweat lodges
you know so
basically our our society have known for
Millennia if you send Warriors out to
war when they come back you got to help
them reintegrate well we so-called
modern society people have forgotten a
lot of that and you know our that's why
the suicide rate of now the number is is
is
questionable uh you know the VA there
was at one point they said 22 plus per
day veterans now we're not talking about
active we're talking about
veterans Were Dying by Suicide recently
they said well it's like 17 frankly we
found Studies by
nonv people who say it's much higher
than that and but one is too many yeah
per day and so uh we basically are
trying to educate the public because
moral injury is not a death
sentence just like PTSD is not you you
got to the way more and by the way when
I go out I give a defin uh what
definition of moral injury is you know
as you know from the book I'm pretty
simple-minded guy and I try to you know
boil things down to their Essentials so
moral
injury goes like this from the time
you're born until you're 18 years old
you develop a personal moral code a
sense of right or wrong that could come
from your family your religion your
friends your community
whatever then you join the
military and you learn a warrior code
the warrior code is superimposed on your
personal moral code and in fact
transforms it somewhat and then you
might have to participate in operations
or activities that violate your personal
moral code such as killing you don't
have to be the person that pulls the
trigger you could be a witness or you
could feel you should have prevented it
or let's say you follow another unit and
you see that innocent civilians have
been killed or you handle body parts at
that time you sustain a so-called
invisible wound of War moral injury and
it is the position of military Outreach
USA
that the main approach for healing moral
injury is not a medical doctor with
prescription
drugs it's the forgiveness and Grace of
a moral Authority a loving
God the counseling of clergy or
sensitive
therapist and the support of a community
offering hope and
help and I can't tell you how many times
I've gone out and given presentations
and afterwards veterans or their spouses
walk up to me in
tears and they
say now I get
it I was told I had PTSD but I know I
don't have
PTSD I've got something
else and and when I give my
presentations I talk about there's a
healing process here number one you have
to know what you have you can't address
the problem unless you know what you
have number
two
is
forgiveness you have to obtain
forgiveness and this is a moral
injury I'm I'm not a I'm not now I I
have to be very clear about all this I'm
not a
psychologist uh psychiatrist social
worker I'm just a guy who's those boots
and shared some of these things with my
own moral injury that I've talked about
in the book uh and I've been doing this
for 20-some years now with
veterans uh and I've
seen uh really good competent
psychologist at the VA who have helped
veterans um and so that's the second
part of and forgiveness could be
something that happens quick or could
take a long
time uh the third part of the healing
process is when when you have moral
injury you feel as if you have
participated in such bad
things that you have no sense of
self-worth you are worthless nobody can
love you God can't love you in fact you
get mad at God which is okay he can take
it
but you know you're really you feel that
you have no worth at all that's why
people with moral injury will not talk
to their
families about it because they fear well
there are two things number one they
want to protect them from what they've
experienced but number two they don't
want to lose their self-respect or their
their love so they don't talk about it
you know and what we do is we try to
educate the public I.E the families of
veterans because we found out that you
know vets normally will not admit that
they got a problem it's you know suck it
up move forward you know don't show a
sign of
weakness I get all that stuff but it's
not right and often times it's the
family the spouses
that forc the veteran to get help you
know it's either like it's either me or
you know I'm gone unless you get help
that type of thing so we're trying to
educate the families and also to let the
families know that this is not something
they've done
wrong you know and they can help and so
we try to get veterans to understand
this
uh and seek help uh through you know
different opportunities that are
available and um so I I wanted to get
that right out front about uh the
passions of what I'm into now today in
my life I've been so blessed and I'm
hoping that this book will educate and
encourage people it's not about Jim
mukama uh in fact uh people who read the
book will see that I have no
acknowledgement section in the book and
the reason I don't is I mention as many
names as I can the whole book is an
acknowledgement you know of people
because it's not about me it's about how
how God has given me blessings and
encouragement through all these people
that have been my mentors that have
helped me uh become what I can be and
that is to serve others that's my life
my life mission at a very early age and
I I know I talk about this in the book
when I was 9 years old and I have no
reason I still I I I try to rethink you
know why would a nine-year-old do this
but one day I said to myself self why
are you here what is
your you know what's your mission you
know and my answer was
to try to serve and help
people and just I I you know I wasn't
looking to find a cure for cancer I
wasn't you know looking to be this great
you know leader or whatever all I wanted
to do is help people and I figured if
everybody did
that you
know the world would
improve you know if everybody had that
type of a a mission or a purpose in life
and I only found out later as my faith
matured about really servant
leadership which is you know which is
what my faith teaches and the best
servant leader of all times in my
opinion was Jesus because he's the guy
who gave up his
life for us and in fact if you read the
Bible he says you know I didn't come
here to be served served I came to serve
others and that to me you know servant
leadership one of the best books I've
read on on leadership was something
called the servant by James Hunter and
it's it's fictional but it it talks what
he does is he takes the the leader ERS
ship pyramid so to speak and he turns it
upside down and he said instead of the
leaders being at the top with all
everybody else down kind of at the
bottom it's everybody else on top and
the leader at the
bottom when you when you speak about
this stuff what was it like what was
your experience like and you write about
in the book but your experience like
coming home and reintegrating yourself
that was a a really you know another
thing I should say is that I always
thought when I was a kid and growing up
that I led a a normal life you know I
was an American I was just you know I I
was enjoying life uh and you know I
didn't realize until later when I got
experience as as a young
officer uh in combat and then dealing
with veterans later I have led an
abnormal life because I've had a stable
nuclear family I've had a strong faith
Foundation I had you know my wonderful
wife of 52 years who's put up with me
and you know guys it doesn't get any
better than that and then Plus which
which we haven't talked about here but I
I I will now among these God things that
I mentioned uh I'm an agent orange
Survivor uh and so you know I've always
been pretty healthy I've I've been into
martial arts um oh yeah I should say
something about martial arts even though
I'm sitting across from one of the best
I you know and martial arts of course
was part of the Samurai tradition and
all that
uh as a young kid I
realized I have a problem with
anger anger management and again it's
amazing how I realize this at such an
early age but I I have a
terrible temper that I have to control
and so I worked on that as a kid Okay so
and I was always the smallest the
smallest guy in in my classes and so the
bullies and the on the playground used
to pick on me you know because I was an
inviting Target right
well I knew I had to control
myself and and so I just brushed it off
you know I Shrugged it off and I just
said I considered the source and all
that and but but one day once again I
was about 9 years old in the playground
the big bully called me a jamp and I
lost it I literally lost it I had him on
the ground in about 10 seconds and I was
on top of him and I was beating him okay
so kids were pulling me off of him you
know and they're saying where's the Jim
mukama that we knew you know and and I
didn't I didn't break anything the guy
you know the guy was more embarrassed
than anything else and I was never
picked on again in in the playground but
so I'm just giving you the background
that I I've I've had this problem I
still have it that I know my temper
needs to be controlled so that's why I
got into martial arts because if anybody
is really a student of martial arts they
understand that it's really
self-discipline and
self-control that you're really studying
and and in fact once you get to a
certain level I know I'm preaching in
the choir with you and Echo but you know
once you get to a certain level you can
do serious damage you know but the good
news is you know you can also control
the
situation and you don't have to prove it
because you know you can do
it so I studied martial arts to be able
to control myself for
self-discipline and I you know I got I
was very I never made a black belt I
it's a long story about that I I
actually when when our son came along
Jay you know uh and you know my wife's
Korean and Jay is adopted from Korea uh
we got into taekwando so I did it with
him you know here I am 40 something
years old right you know I was in pretty
good shape though I mean I wasn't a
slacker and uh so I worked my way up to
he got a black belt before he like he
was 10 you know and but we started him
very early though and then I got I got
up to a brown belt and then I injured
myself
and pretty much endered my my career I
mean I could have gone back you know but
by that time I was
now the
general I had a few other things going
on in life you know like Desert Storm
and things like that but uh but that
that's my experience with you know
self-control and and the martial arts
which I I I was fortunate because at the
University of Illinois I actually joined
the karate club at at the ufi and the
teacher was the Sensei was one of our
students who had a black belt
and this was the Japan Karate
Association jka which is really the
classical stuff none of this you know
show thing it was it was really and it
was really tough though it you know I
mean I was happy to get a yellow belt I
got to tell you I'm not kidding you know
uh but then later on I did the taond
stuff and I got up to a brown belt so I
I've I've been blessed and did that uh
perspective help you when you were
coming back back and reintegrating into
you know coming home from Vietnam now
you're going from active duty into the
reserve
components and having to kind of carry
on having to find the next phase in your
life yeah I'm that's right I kind of got
off the track all good we we talk about
martial arts that's always a little
tangent we're happy to
take but yeah integration for me uh from
Vietnam was once again abnormal for
those times now you'll get what I'm
getting at uh when we came back from
Vietnam and it's hard for for young
military today to understand this we
were told when we landed in California
not to wear our uniforms MH to take our
uniforms off because we were spit upon
people through excrement and urine at us
and called us baby killers and you know
and was it was brutal let me just say
that and in fact a very dear friend of
mine who just passed away uh Vietnam
veteran with the
101st uh this poor guy was from San
Francisco and and uh he was Italian and
he was raised
Catholic uh and so he goes to
Vietnam uh was a platoon leader saw a
lot of combat uh came back to and he
wasn't he wasn't real happy uh coming
back from Vietnam from this whole
experience but he he lands in San
Francisco and all
this crap occurs you know and so he's
back and you know some of his friends
and even family had disown him or
whatever and and so he goes to his
priest
right thinking that he's going to get
some you know some sensitive or some you
know response and and the priest said
you were in
Vietnam he said and you fought in
Vietnam you're going to
hell and so he turns around and he
doesn't go back you know now later on in
life he he's he he was able ble to
forgive the priest
and uh you don't forget those things
that just like Jane Fonda I might add
I've got to get this out too with Jane
Fonda
was the definition of
treason is to give Comfort to the enemy
during wartime she did that in Spades
going to North Vietnam sitting at an
anti-aircraft
gun that was being used to shoot down
American planes wearing an NVA
helmet and she's an actress with you
know World popularity you know the the
you know daughter of Henry Fonda and and
there she is giving
propaganda just gold to to the enemy
right so Vietnam
veterans hate her
that I'm trying to be kind when I say
that but to give you an idea one of the
favorite sales items for Vietnam
veterans are urinal covers with her
photo on
it and so and I and I'm I'm not proud of
this but I'll I'll just tell you that I
for many decades guys I mean
decades I hated that woman so much had
there been a call for a firing Squad I
would have been the first guy in line I
mean that's how much I hated this woman
okay well once again through the grace
of God and my faith I have come to
understand
that I can forgive her I cannot forget
what happened and I can I when I say I
can forgive her I can stop hating her
and stop letting that
bitterness control me and that's one of
the things about moral injury is that
you don't want to let the past control
your
present and you have to think of moving
forward and so I
have it it was like a big weight lifted
off my shoulder when when I said you
know I forgive her I'm moving on you
know and really it's not really for me
to forgive her it's for God to forgive
her because only he knows what's in her
heart and I've never heard
her sincerely apologize for what she did
did and you know say that you know she's
sorry for what she did to the veterans
and their families and you know I mean
she could do a little restitution Maybe
you know like donate to you know
veterans organizations or something uh
but I've never seen that and so uh but
she's got to live with that and I'm not
in control that MH so where were we well
no that's that talks about coming home
and you know how difficult that was yeah
the the reason why mine was abnormal
again was my church supported me during
Vietnam when I was in Vietnam they sent
me packages which was not the norm in
those days okay and uh one of the
funniest things is the thing I treasured
the most about the packages is they sent
me packets of soy sauce because I I was
going to a Japanese American church
right so you know in the mess hle I
couldn't get you know I was lucky to get
rice every now and then it was mostly
you know Uncle Ben's or something it
wasn't you know Asian rice and so anyway
that was uh but they when I came home
they treated me like a hero and the
reason for that is our
congregation was constituted of many
World War II veterans who had fought in
the 100th Battalion 442nd regimental
combat team uh during World War II and
it served in the military intelligence
service so they knew what you know and
they wanted to talk to me about it you
know cuz I was an infantry guy you know
i' had seen some combat you know so and
they were so proud of me you know when I
was promoted in the Army and when I
became a general I mean that was that
was huge you know and then later on in
life when I talk about in the book I
I've I've had I I got involved with the
building of a national Japanese American
Memorial in Washington DC that took
seven years out of my life cuz I walked
around the country on my own dime giving
speeches raising money for the memorial
now it's a natur it's a national
Memorial authorized by Congress okay and
they pass a law and what they do is they
they give us the land for the memorial
but that's it so whoever is sponsoring
the memorial has to raise the money to
for the architect for the to build the
memorial Memorial and it has to be
approved by in Washington DC where this
Memorial is at there's like I want to
say a dozen
commissions you know the you know the
Garden Club or the uh national umpty-ump
uh you know commission that you have to
go through to get you know I mean they
control the height the height of the
memorial how far away it is from the
curve uh the m material you can use in
it and all that stuff so for seven years
of my life that's but the neat thing
about it was I would go around the
country to these Japanese American
organizations because nobody else would
donate to this it was seen as a ethnic
Memorial which really was a patriotism
Memorial uh and so I would be with all
these veterans niss veterans who are my
heroes I mean you know how how cool is
that to be able to be with your lifetime
Heroes you know and here I am I'm
meeting all these guys from World War II
who have been through battles they've
been through Prejudice they've been in
camps themselves imagine your 18 years
old you just graduated from high school
right and you get a knock on your door
it's a local FBI agent and he said be on
the corner of State and Madison on
Monday morning with two suitcases
and that's it you know you're put on a
train you you're put in some God
forsaken camp in the middle of nowhere
and you're there for three
years and your family let's say you
owned a
business you know you you can't survive
you know you have you lose your business
you have a home you can't pay the
mortgage because you have no income
because you're in a camp you know and uh
and then the local Army recruiter comes
and he says I want you to go die for
your country and I don't guys I don't
know what I would have done if I were in
their shoes I might have told them to
take a hike you know uh but these guys
volunteered and the reason they
volunteered is they wanted to prove to
the rest of America that americanism is
not a matter of race
we're all red blooded Americans we all
bled red and bleed red and they wanted
to prove that we were loyal the the
Japanese Americans were loyal and the
only way you could prove it was by dying
and that's that's what they did and they
were the difference because of their
example in the European theater of
operation let's say we had 9 million I'm
just using I don't know if that's the
right figure but let's say 9 million
soldiers Sailors Marines you know
serving uh and in combat areas as as Joo
can attest the reputation of units good
and bad spread like
wildfire you know the good units and you
know the ones that are not so good well
the 442nd 100th Battalion
442nd their reputation was off the
charts I mean everybody wanted them uh
you know Fifth Army Commander uh they
just wanted those guys you know and and
uh I was just so blessed so I would go
around giving speeches right and these
guys wanted to have their photo taken
with the general you know cuz you know
most of them were enlisted men right and
we know you know if you're enlisted
you know the company Commander who's a
captain is like a god right and and so a
general I mean they they hardly ever get
to speak see one much much less speak to
one right so i' go to these events and
they all want to get their pictures we
didn't have selfies in those days but
they would you know they wanted to get
their picture taken with me and and I on
the other hand I wanted to get my
picture taken with them of course so it
was so my
return and integration back into society
was was smooth to say the least because
my church really supported me uh when I
came back they immediately they said we
want you to teach the
teenagers you know and I said I'm in you
know because I wasn't that far much
older than they were at that time you
know and so I I did that and uh got very
you know active and
in the church and everything and so uh
it was unusual it was abnormal once
again which some people might think is
normal it was really abnormal and that
helped my healing and my ability to
integrate back into society which most
of my peers did not have because of the
rejection like my friend that I told you
about where the priest yeah told them
you know that's crazy it it was you know
that's the kind of stuff that happened
you know and so it's it's like uh cancel
culture 50 years ago you know where they
found out that they had you know people
guys in the reserves you know because we
had to have our hair cut short you know
people could see right away we're
military guys in the reserves used to
wear wigs D you know during the week you
know so people wouldn't know that they
were you know that's how bad it was it
was it was incredible but I had a smooth
integration very blessed and you um you
end up uh you you know getting great
stories that you write about in the book
when you went out to you already talked
about it here but you know you went out
to San Francisco on a trip with your
cousin you end up meeting your wife KJ
you guys you know hit it off and get
married uh well there it's not
quite it's it's I I have to be very
accurate about this okay she it was for
me love at first sight I mean I just I
knew the the moment I saw her uh it
wasn't quite the same on the other side
I was just some guy who was showing up
and living with your parents didn't have
a job yeah not exactly not exactly a
catch there moo that's right that's
right so you had some convincing to do
yeah I did but uh once again that's the
God thing I talk those are the type of
things in my life that you know are
almost unheard
of things that happen and you you so
once you're married you you actually end
up adopting two kids yes um first Sumi
right right and then Jay who's the by
the way thanks Jay Jay connected us
originally for the original podcast he
heard heard me talking so um and and as
you're doing this as you now you got
kids and as you're raising these kids uh
you you end up creating the mukama
family
code which is a document that you've got
in the appendix of the book and this
thing is classic I recommend you know
when when you all read the book get the
book these are just just to burn just to
run through some of the highlights of
this um General tenants have faith in be
grateful to God obey the laws of God in
our country always tell the truth if you
do something bad admit it and apologize
and you go on with these really good ten
be be polite and use good manners try
try your best in everything you do and
you go on with this stuff you you have a
list of daily conduct like make bed at
Meal Time set the table say grace sit up
straight don't talk with a mouthful of
food eat all that you take request
permission to leave the table take
dishes and cups to the sink help clean
up brush teeth after every meal and
snack so you go through kind of the
daily conduct that people and then
you've got this thing called prohibited
action
which you mentioned in the book that
maybe that wasn't the best you know
psychological way to do but I actually
think it's great you know things like do
not brag about your accomplishments or
possessions do not be discouraged by
failure or disappointments don't talk
back or interrupt your elders or
teachers do not abuse your body by
smoking drugs or alcohol do not be
jealous of others do not be greedy do
not be nasty or try to hurt other people
so you've got these really good T it
goes on but I'm just kind of uh jumping
through some of them get the book so you
can get the whole list um but that's the
kind of thing that's in here that
really those are really great tenants uh
well you know that that book by the way
uh you know our the reason we did that
is our kids were very young when we put
that out by the way they were like four
and five years old okay they were like
there's a lot of rules Mom and Dad yeah
come on but the surprising thing though
you'll be surprised to hear this at four
and five years old
I you know we we we kind of make it a we
made it a special occasion right Mom and
Dad have a surprise for you you know
that's always you know and and uh you
know these are kids who can't read
cursive or can't actually read a lot you
know so I printed everything uh on on
the original mukama Family Code using uh
colored markers you know to make it
interesting for them they were all in
plastic pages and then our daughter's
favorite color was purple so I put it in
a purple binder right it became known as
the purple book because the advant the
whole purpose of it was one day KJ and I
were talking and we said you know if
something happens to us if God takes us
while the kids are still young we want
them to know
what our values are for the mukoyama
family okay and so that's why that was
the purpose of it the benefit that we
received which I did not
anticipate was that number one when we
had the special occasion we had ice
cream you know after dinner and then so
so I go ahead and read Page by Page item
by item about this at four and five
years old they understood about 85% of
it it's pretty good you know so but the
other benefit was as they got older in
life okay if they did something that
upset us or got me mad okay instead of
my going on a tantrum I'd say let's get
the purple book out okay and you see
this line where it says you know don't
be greedy or don't you know don't be
jealous of of your friends if they're
successful but rather be happy for
them do you know why Papa was not wasn't
real happy with you today they couldn't
say you never told
me well that idea of living by a code is
something that I put in the way the
warrior kid books there's a warrior kid
code in there and also I tried to find
it but I had in my house when my kids
were younger willink family Rules and I
tried to find it mine was definitely not
as long as yours I I I didn't go that I
didn't go that hard in the pain as you
did but I tried to find it I'm going to
try and find it I think I've got it I've
got a copy of it somewhere I wasn't able
to find it um you know obviously there
were some similar things in there but
same thing you know just knowing what
the standard is and then if you violate
the standard there's here's what the
consequences are well you know the
military so I have a master's degree in
the teaching of social studies Okay the
reason I did that even though I was
going to make the military career you
know I knew I was going to be infantry I
knew I was going to Vietnam so the odds
of my being wounded and perhaps disabled
were were not small so I had to have a
profession to fall back on and as you
and I have talked about both being
English Majors English was isn't the the
uh greatest livelihood producer shall we
say and so I had to have a backup
profession and something that doesn't
didn't require me to run the 20 yard
dash and it was teaching which I always
considered to be an honorable profession
you know so I I made I I got my degree
in the teaching of social studies the
reason I'm saying all this is that you
me mention about the military uh I found
out that I was taking all these graduate
courses of history and philosophy of
education psychology of education and I
learned that the military had one of the
best training programs anywhere which
was tasks conditions standards yep
indeed you know you let them know what
the task is you tell them the conditions
under which it's going to happen and you
tell them the standards that you expect
them to meet no slack and that's work
very well it does work well that's for
sure um I'm gonna fast forward again you
got to get the book there's all kinds of
stuff that I'm uh skipping over
otherwise I'd just be reading the whole
book which you know you need to do for
yourselves out there listeners but fast
forward a little bit my near quarter
Century of service in the Army Reserves
because you got when you got out of the
regular army you joined the reserves was
marked with challenging yet fulfilling
assignments I commanded at every level
company Battalion Brigade and Division
in every instance I had great
non-commissioned officers who luckily
made me look good and mentors who gave
me challenging assignments to grow and
didn't hand me my head on a platter when
I screwed up these individuals gave me
the opportunity to reach my fullest
potential my leadership philosophy also
empowered me to rise through the ranks
by Leading with care and balance I set
out to be an example for my
troops and then you say when I was
promoted to Brigade General onear I was
the youngest General in the Army at the
time at the age of 42 years old
subsequently I became the youngest Major
General two star 3 years later at 45
years old when I took command of the 7
70th Division I was the first
Asian-American in the history of the US
Army to command a
division so you kind of powered up
through the
ranks and um again lots of good
Leadership Lessons Learned in there you
got a bunch of stories about that but I
want to fast forward here to a situation
that
really uh really changed your your
course in the Army he said the Army had
to reduce its forces instead of using
the established process the top brass
the chief of staff of the army the chief
of the Army Reserve and the chief of the
National Guard and the presidents of the
reserve Officers Association and the
National Guard Association of the United
States met in a hotel room away from the
Pentagon and made a Smoke Filled Room
deal in essence it decimated the Army
Reserve Aviation by 80% and eliminated
the two Reserve Special Forces groups
and kept the two National Guard groups
neither did decision was defendable in
terms of military Readiness which in
fact was significantly degraded it was a
purely political
decision so this happens and you were
you were president of the Army Reserve
Association at the time and after this
decision gets made which is going to
cause all kinds of damage to like you
said to the the def the Readiness of the
country military Readiness the next
morning at 8:00 a.m. the AR that's the
Army Reserve Association issued a press
release saying the so-called offsite
agreement did not have the support of
the men and women of the Army Reserve
Association due to the detrimental
effect it would have on our nation's
Readiness The Washington Post ran a
front page article with several quotes
from the AR
newsletter soon thereafter Army
reservice and Army Reserve civilian
employees from throughout the country
pleaded with me to testify someone had
to stand up I remembered when I was a
young officer in Vietnam vowing that if
I ever got to a position of authority to
protect my soldiers and Nation I would
do so unlike the generals and Admirals
who failed to do so in Vietnam because
they allowed themselves to be handcuffed
by the Elites in Washington I remembered
how Colonel hackworth stood up and
voiced his apprehensions about the
Vietnam War although his military career
deteriorated after sharing his concerns
he demon he demonstrated that his troops
and their well-being was far more
important than
himself by standing up for his values
Colonel hackworth chose to set a strong
example of courageous and caring
leadership I had to decide whether I
would follow his lead my opportunity to
choose soon came as president of the
Army Reserve Association I was invited
not subpoena to testify before a
congressional subcommittee about the the
off-site agreement I could have excused
Myself by saying I had a conflict or
just declined but as a leader within the
Army Reserves it was my
responsibility I needed to honor the
reservists I was serving with and
leading I had to tell the truth even if
no one else would I accepted prior to
testifying we had a family kitchen
meeting where I presented the reality of
the situation I informed my family that
testifying would most likely end my army
career and our lives would
change so I appeared before Congress
telling the truth I asserted that the
sweeping overhaul of the Army Reserves
would endanger soldiers lives degrade
our military Readiness and waste our
taxpayers money this off-site decision
was halfhazard and the guards lack of
preparedness would damage the US
military's tactical missions and Grand
strategy standing in front of Congress I
maintained that politics should not be
be allowed to override military
considerations Colonel hackworth had
also stood his ground to defend what was
right so he knew what consequences were
coming next for me in his nationally
syndicated column he tried to cover my
six and protect my back by writing a
column entitled moral cowardice end
dangers
soldiers he detailed my testimony before
Congress and the background of the
so-called off-site agreement based upon
his own experience with the guard and
reserves he agreed with my assessment
that this haphazard decision was
endangering troops by disregarding their
tactical competence hackworth stressed
that quote courage is as much a part of
soldiering as
gunpowder but having guts isn't just
about charging the enemy it is also
about Standing Tall against wrongdoing
and fighting for what's right end quote
I greatly appreciated his cover and
conscious and hackworth's own example of
Courage was one of the reasons I spoke
out and told the
truth it was unfortunately to no avail
one year later I was history and my
career came screeching to a halt but sud
suddenly there were no assignments
available for me because I was so young
I had five more years remaining before
my mandatory retirement date I got the
message and I
retired
you followed in hackworth's footsteps
once again well but once I that's true
what what I classified that as another
God thing which was that he was in fact
my wife when this all happened and I'm
having now I'm having kind of a pity
party cuz you know my 32-year career has
just gone literally down the drain right
and so KJ says to me wait a second she
said you know you survive Vietnam yeah
actually two combat tours Korea
Vietnam and U you had your Asian orange
experience where you had your kidney
transplant where our adopted daughter
was the donor by the way uh and a match
which was another God thing uh
and and I have reached the rank of major
general which at that time was the
highest rank a Reserve officer could
attain
[Music]
and you married
me so how how could I argue that what
you complaining about that's right and
and you know she was right and it was
time for me you know God was giving me a
message that this chapter in my life uh
is has ended he's got other plans for me
and I just said okay whatever Let's uh
let's move forward and see what you have
in in store for me you go into a section
here that's just about and you mentioned
one of the ways that you were able to
serve after the Army um but you go
through a list of things and not just a
list you go through the stories and and
Lessons Learned From various things that
you got involved with afterwards the
first of which is volunteering in in
hospice which uh you did that your wife
KJ she got her degree and she was uh
going out and volunteering herself and
so you two actually volunteered together
in
hospice what what did you learn from
seeing that side of death I know
obviously you'd seen death on the
battlefield this is a very different
kind of death when you people go into
hospice care what what did you take away
from that yeah I appreciate you asking
me that Joo because it gives me an
opportunity to educate people about
hospice first of all uh number one uh
hospice is for people who have been
diagnosed with a terminal illness with a
prognosis of less than 6 months to live
okay once a person has reach those
criteria they're eligible for hospice
hospice is one of the most wonderful
services
that
our
society has has volunteers who are
willing to do this uh a hospice team is
comprised of a doctor a nurse a
certified nurses
assistant a therapist could be physical
could be spiritual a CH
chaplain and a hospice patient
volunteer okay all of this is provided
at no cost to the patient and by the way
the unit of care is not only the patient
it's also the
caregiver because often times the
caregiver is the one who needs the
help and the person who is dying
sometimes doesn't even know what's going
on
uh but almost all all know no matter
what uh you know we're we're taught
we're train that uh even when a a
patient is lying in a bed can't talk
don't open their eyes you
assume that they can hear everything
that's going
on and you treat them as if they're part
of the
conversation you don't never say
anything negative in front of them uh
which could you know be really Downer so
to speak um and so and the way the way I
got involved in it was KJ saw this ad
for a very wonderful hospice
organization called Rainbow hospice in
the Chicago area where we live and they
offered
training s but it was like a six week
training program in the evening a couple
days a week you know and you know being
the guy that I am I I didn't want her to
go out at night you know by herself so I
said well I'll drive you and I'll take a
book or I'll take work with me you know
while you're going through the training
I'll just kind of you know do my thing
well I got sucked up into the training
with her because I've I've I've always
always tried to help her whenever she's
when she was in school and and uh I
helped her with her her studies and so
uh I got involved in the training so we
both were qualified as hospice patient
volunteers now the average at least at
that time the average hospice patient
volunteer lasted about 18
months uh the reason for that it is
extremely
strenuous uh
stressful uh you know you understand the
contract you know the person is
dying okay and you're there to provide
comfort and help to not only them but to
the family or caregiver so you you come
in as a patient volunteer for maybe
three hours at a time so that the
caregiver can take a break
maybe they can take a nap maybe they can
go to a movie maybe they can you know
get their hair set or do whatever and we
take care of the patient so uh we did
that for six and a half years and it was
it was stressful but the good news is we
could help each other and lean on each
other the the way what happened was in
our training we were told that that uh
and it makes sense it's it's not easy to
get hosp patient volunteers so each team
has one patient volunteer so she so KJ
and I would be SP we're going to be
split up now you know because she'll be
with one patient and I'll be with
another patient you know and one day a
friend of ours who and I talk about it
in the book A friend of ours whose
husband had died from cancer uh was
visiting us
and and um we we told her about what we
were doing and she said you know the the
most effective help I got when my
husband was going through the cancer was
when a married couple
came to visit us cuz the husband would
spend time with my husband and the wife
would spend time with me okay so all
kinds of bells and whistles go off in
our mind so we go to our hospice patient
volunteer and we said hey you know have
you ever thought of assigning you know a
husband and wife as a
team you know for hospice and she said
you are the first husband and wife team
that's ever trained here so she said
we'll give it a shot and that's what we
did and so that's how you know we were
able to last so long uh in that and I'll
tell you the the to answer your initial
question the Insight I got into dying
was a totally different thing in terms
of
uh people of
Faith really handle it much better and I
can make that general statement because
we did that for six and a half years and
uh
it
was and and most and a lot of people who
are dying cared more for us than they
cared about their situation because they
could see that we were volunteering and
helping them but it was
also you know stra stressful for us and
I'll never forget we had one one patient
who
uh a Chinese lady who didn't speak
English so we and she never spoke we
never heard her speak to us while we
were there this was a lovely story her
caregiver was a woman from South
America who uh her name the the patients
name was Mrs Chen and her caregiver was
related to her through marriage you know
Mrs Chen's nephews you know married this
other woman's second cousin or something
and this other woman was a professional
CNA and so she took Mrs Chen into her
home and set aside a bedroom just for
her and she was her
caregiver okay and so that you the
relationship was so beautiful you know
from two different cultures uh and so
anyway what I'm getting at is when it
came when she was dying I mean we knew
the end was coming fairly soon you know
and and kji and I visited her and we
were
leaving and Mrs Chen said thank you I
mean it was
like out of the blue you know and it was
like she was saying goodbye to us cuz
she knew that she didn't have and we had
other wonderful experiences I had a
Vietnam veteran who who was an enlisted
man and an army guy a man of Great
Character obviously and and he when he
found out I was a general and he was in
a wheelchair and he had cancer and I I
was taking him around the facility you
know and he would tell everybody I have
a general who's taking me around you
know and then he said uh this was the
touching part he he said you know
General when I beat this thing that guy
was a fighter you know and he had cancer
and he said when I beat this thing I'm
going to become a hospice patient
volunteer like you and
KJ man I got to tell you that's so when
he died we had a policy of not going to
funerals I mean it it just would have
been too hard and too many frankly uh
and but we went to his funeral and he
was Greek and his mother uh immigrated
from Greece uh her husband had been
killed in the Greek Civil War and he uh
it was just he and her and he was like
65 or something and just retired from
government service and never married and
you know he was devoted to his mom and
she was devoted to him and he had
planned to take her around the world on
a
as a gift and then the guy gets cancered
so so we go to the funeral at this you
know Chicago is a a city of
neighborhoods and of ethnicities okay
well there's this one funeral home that
most of the Greeks go to you know and so
we we go to the funeral service and you
know we're the only non- Greeks they
much less only Asians right and his
mother knew exactly who we were and she
was so grateful to us and uh so yeah
hospice was a a very eye openening but
I'm very we're very grateful that we had
that experience and it really taught us
about dying how people can be so
gracious yeah definitely a incredible
way to serve as well um you end up also
and again these are these are things
that you had the opportunity to serve
and that's what you call them
opportunities to serve you end up doing
uh work with the Veterans Affair with
the vas with the VA um and then what you
already mentioned with with putting
together that that memorial for the
World War II veterans and one thing that
was interesting about that you were in
charge of making sure that all the names
that were going to be on this uh
Memorial were accurate and at one point
um they they wanted to
um yeah I know where you're going they
wanted to omit the names of The
non-japanese Americans who served in
those in those units now IE they were
the officers because although the unit
you know at that time the military was
segregated so they put together this
Japanese American
unit but they all the officers were
Caucasian or non non Japanese there was
actually a Korean Captain who who was
who was assigned and he blessed his soul
his name is uh Colonel
uh Young Oak Kim uh
he was given the opportunity by the
commander regimental Commander not to
serve because he was Korean and he knew
the animosity between the Koreans and
Japanese knes and Colonel Kim to his
credit said these are Americans I'm an
American mhm you know I will not be
transferred I'll serve with them and he
was with the the hund yeah uh but yeah
you you say the units originally had
Caucasian officers many of whom died in
combat there was some objection to
listing their names because they were
not of Japanese ancestry being a combat
veteran I immediately squashed such
nonsense this was a national American
Memorial to deny those soldiers this
honor would have been reverse
discrimination of the worst kind I
permitted no further discussion yeah it
was kind of nice to be a general
sometimes because a lot of the people on
the committee were former service
members but you know it was so
ridiculous yeah I just said that's it
you know I've got
enough trouble trying to make sure the
names were correct uh you know there
were 830 plus names that eventually got
on the memorial and you know we
dedicated it in
2000 uh knock on wood for those not on
can't see me I'm hitting my forehead but
uh there have been no changes no
Corrections that's impressive the names
it's impressive uh and then the fifth
opportunity that you talk about in the
book to serve was helping with the
Navy with uh getting a religious program
inside uh the basic training center in
there in Chicago yeah that was that was
interesting uh a very dear friend of
mine his name was Joe gray he was a uh a
major general in the Army Reserves when
I was in fact when I was uh active as a
general we go to these these General
officer conferences and Joe was a strong
man of faith in fact uh in his civilian
life he was the public relations guy uh
for
uh um the 700 Club I mean so he you know
he was a very strong Christian and he he
got involved with the military Ministry
of Campus Crusade for Christ and so he
calls me one day and he said Jim do you
know anybody at Great Lakes you know I'm
an army guy you know I don't I don't
know the Navy guys you know and and I
said no I don't he said listen you know
we're trying to get into Great
Lakes to give these classes to help to
help
supplement the command religious program
and we're already at Fort Benning with
the Infantry Army we're already with the
Marines we're already with the Air Force
at lacklin Air Force Space we can't we
haven't been able to break the code at
Great Lakes okay cuz Great Lakes is is
the Navy's only recruit training center
now they closed out the other two so so
I said well I'll give it a shot but you
know I can't promise you anything so I
call up there and I and I say this is
Major General retired Jim
mukoyama uh can I speak to the Admiral
who was you know the I just I wasn't
going to you know stop and go and
collect $200 so so I kept right through
right and I say Admiral uh you know we
have a program I'd like to introduce you
to an organization that is willing to
come and volunteer to
supplement your chaplain's command
religious program could we come talk to
you sure bring them up okay so I called
Joe greyback I said okay now your you I
got the tow in the water you got to you
got to make it swim right and so we go
up there and and uh the rest is history
and it's is that still active right now
oh yeah very much so in fact in the
epilogue of my book okay for I
volunteered for 20 years as an
instructor at the chapel at Great Lakes
okay now I didn't go every Sunday i r
about two Sundays a month but you know
for 20 years you know because I this is
it was always on Sunday MH so I'd have
to miss my church on Sunday you know but
I was willing to do that cuz I wanted to
recruit see I I didn't care if they
stayed in the Navy for a career I wanted
them to have the foundation in life that
I had to get them through what they're
going to struggle with in life and if
they have that that's good enough for me
okay so for 20 years I volunteered as an
instructor at the chapel our average
attendance was maybe between 20 and 50
recruits okay now you have to understand
the chapel there seats
1200 okay that's kind of lonely in there
with 20 people yeah so well no the
chapel had this main CH the the building
had its main chapel and then had smaller
chapels okay okay so we get obviously a
smaller Chapel so for 19 years that was
the average Co hits okay we had to
closed down for about a year and a half
you know because the base was closed you
know to Outsiders okay then they
reopened it and we changed from Sunday
classes to Friday night
classes so what that did was when
recruits went on Sunday
some had to choose between services and
our class now they didn't have to do
that they could just come to our
services if they wanted to all this of
course is voluntary
right our attendance well two things
number one CO's over so people now could
Fellowship together which they hadn't
been able to do for over a year okay
number two we we had we had access to
them without having to fight the the
services our attendant
exploded literally exploded we and I
told you we we had these small chaples
then we got larger chapels then we got
the
chapel
okay my last class was September
30th last year
and I get up there from my last class
the chapel was
packed
1,200
recruits and I'm I'm up there giving my
class and I'm looking out there and I'm
saying to myself only God it was just
incredible um I guess what you already
talked about what I would say is right
now the the uh the Pinnacle of what
you've done for for outreach and helping
people and and that's the um military
Outreach usa.org and you've talked about
what programs you're running there and
how that's helping people out and what's
the what's the current status of that
military Outreach actually is is doing
quite well uh we have
expanded our program we've actually
teamed up with an organization in
Alabama called Crosswinds
foundation and they published two
DVDs one is called invisible
scars and that talks about
PTSD the second one and the way this
happened was I saw that first
video uh about 5 years ago and it was
was the best thing I've seen on PTSD at
up to that point cuz they had individual
soldiers Sailors
Marines give their
stories and they gave their names they
gave their services and the wars that
they were in and it was and then they
had chaplain they had social workers and
psychologists okay talk about PTSD and
what could be done Etc so I called him I
said hey I want you to know this is the
greatest thing since life bread that
I've seen are you thinking of doing one
on moral
injury pregnant pause right and and the
guy said well general you know we're
like your your organization military
Outreach we're small you know really
local organization we don't have a lot
of
funding and and I said his name was Bob
wal Alp he's the he's the guy who runs
it and I said Bob we're losing 22 plus
veterans a day we got to move on this
it's it's the same thing like in Vietnam
after Vietnam PTSD was ignored for agent
orange was ignored for decades you know
and vets were dying and suffering and
they weren't getting the aid that they
could have gotten you know and so I said
you know we we can't wait we got to take
action on this so i' appreciate if you
could think about it you know couple
weeks later he calls me back he said
we're in okay then he puts the monkey on
my back and he said oh by the way do you
know any veterans who have moral injury
that would be willing to talk do I know
veterans with moral injury I mean I had
a whole bunch of them lined up they came
up to Chicago
they did filming of the DVD so the
second DVD is called honoring the code
and it's all about moral injury you know
and the purpose of these
DVDs is to educate the public encourage
people who have it to seek assistance
because it's there and as I said earlier
it's
not it is not a death sentence this can
be beat and it but it's got to be with
people who understand it and the person
has to seek the help are these things
available online anywhere you you can
actually go to Crosswinds foundation.org
and they don't charge for this I you can
I think it's streaming okay yeah I was
going to say because I don't even have a
DVD player anymore so I hope it's
streaming if it's not streaming we'll
we'll figure out a way to make that work
they used to
uh they they used
to uh mail them to people that free of
charge to Veterans or family
members again that's nice but if they're
not streaming we'll work with them to
make sure we get that thing they get
those two videos somewhere where people
can just watch them yeah right on demand
as soon as they hear about them so we'll
make sure that's uh that's happening
um again so much stuff to cover in the
book um it's just the book is is
wonderful uh I'm going to fast forward
here and kind of kind of wrap up what
I'm going to read again get the book
everybody so that you can you can get
the rest of the story here you say this
people have often asked me Jim why are
you so happy how are you so optimistic
and peaceful what makes you see the
glass half full instead of half empty
peace is not the absence of War but
rather the OB of fear and when your life
is not controlled by fear you have joy I
have learned and stood by these two
definitions through my faith and they
give me a steady peace of mind this
mindset doesn't mean that I am always
wearing Rose Colored Glasses nor is it
the case that I have never doubted my
abilities or the outcome of a crucial
situation doubt is not bad it generates
a realistic assessment and plan of
action but I understand that God has a
plan and I do not fear
what he has planned for me I'm going to
close out my reading from the book with
this section here you say in my lifetime
I have faced obstacles that I could have
used as excuses I could have dwell on my
short stature minority status or lower
class background casting myself as a
victim but if I spend all my time
contemplating these disadvantages I
would never have had my success or
blessings I chose to be optimistic about
my future and remain grateful for the
past and present life is a constant
experience of choices it is crucial to
understand that you alone control your
choices and how you react to your
circumstances A major advantage Falls to
those who appreciate the blessings they
have received in life rather than those
who accept the woe is me attitude and
blame their unfortunate
circumstances on
others and as you say we control our
choices and how we react to our
circumstances that is indeed true and
you are certainly an
extraordinary uh example of that well I
I do talk about right at the end of the
book or in the last chapter speaking of
choices about a Dr Edith Ed edar whom I
met here in San Diego actually and you
probably know her because she she was a
a holocaust
Survivor she
after after World War II she got her PhD
and and she's but she is actually
trained for the Armed Forces about
choices and pos positive approach to
life
and she's you know her whole thing is we
all have choices in life and she said
she could have chosen to you know be a
victim I mean you know family members
were killed she went through some pretty
horrible experiences and yet today she's
uh what you know I haven't spoken to her
for a while so I hope she's still alive
but when I met her she was already like
94 War I think and she when she walked
into the room it you know her presence
there was just an aura about her of
positivity and
Grace and uh she was just incredible so
I have a in the book there's a picture
of me with her which was so nice and we
had a wonderful uh woman Rose who was a
holocaust Survivor just incredible and
unfortunately she passed away last year
but I mean you want to talk about um
Survivor she had she had been in line
she she was an alitz she had been in the
line for the gas Chambers like seven
eight or nine times and she would get
put in that line and she would kind of
just sneak out of it and it happened to
her like I said eight or nine times that
she was in the line to be killed in the
gas Chambers and she'd sneak out of that
line when she showed up when she when
she arrived in alwiz they as she was
getting off the train a random person to
her said tell them you're 16 and she
that that's all the person said tell
them you're 16 just real quick and Rose
kind of said okay and they asked her how
old she was she said 16 and she was a
very small woman I think she was 14 at
the time but they put her in a different
line all the people under the age of 16
went right into the gas Chambers and
were killed and so I mean it's just just
the the craziest story but again she's
the same way when she would walk into a
room when when we met her for the first
time it was like a a beam of energy was
coming into the room just an incredible
woman um but yeah and I would say both
same same attitude with both them like
hey we have control over how we respond
to things and that's that's up to us um
one one thing that you have and again
just to just to talk about military
Outreach usa.org
uh I think that's the best place to find
you right now there's also a Facebook
page but but you have as your slogan uh
when you can't walk when you can't run
walk when you can't walk crawl when you
can't crawl we will carry you so that's
uh that's what you're doing right now
and again it's an incredible service to
to the veterans does that get us up to
speed is there anything else to cover
what else besides the book yeah I would
I would say one one other thing about
military Outreach that you asked me how
we how are we doing we've also added a
program uh it's it's uh we this is
another God thing about four years ago
we lost our our executive director which
created a huge hole because this guy was
the guy who authored the book they don't
receive purple hearts and without him we
would have never gotten to where we were
at as an organization and unfortunately
he had a lot of pressures and he had to
uh leave that position so now I'm
looking for an executive director right
I wear this hat this Vietnam veterans
hat wherever I go every day and I do it
because number one I want people to know
that we have veterans in our communities
you know not everybody wears a hat like
I do but you know we have them and it
also generates
conversations and you can understand
this when uh you know when guys are
veterans and they they'll come up to me
and they'll start talking to me you just
out of the blue and it it's like we
we've known each other forever you know
especially when I find out their army
guys or they were in Vietnam you know
and you know how the routine goes when
were you there what unit were you in you
know blah blah blah and and so uh I met
my Cadillac dealer my car dealer and
I've got this hat on there's another guy
with a Vietnam veteran hat on so
immediately you know we Bond we talk I
give them my card I always carry my card
in brochures and about military Outreach
and he said I know a guy who's doing
exactly kind of what you're doing you
know and he's in my American Legion Post
and blah blah blah and I said hey you
know tell him about me and and you know
have him contact me that so he does he
contacts me his name is chappie Farah he
is the current executive director of
military Outreach USA he had his own
501c3 called Stand By Me
Heroes and the whole idea of that is to
reduce the suicide rate sound familiar
and he
basically has what he calls Foxhole Soul
counselors and the whole idea behind it
is one onone peer-to-peer
and so what we do is our offices are
called Dunkin Donuts and we we EST
establish a one-on-one relationship with
a veteran who might need help and once
the trust thing is established that's
the thing you have to do first but once
you can get the trust established then
we can talk about you know the serious
stuff and how to get them help and we
have prevented suicides there were two
two
marines who were had a
pack to they selected a
date they pressed their uniforms they
had their dress uniforms pressed they
cleaned their
weapons and one of them met one of our
foxo soul
counselors who work with him and talk
them out of
it and you know
that's that's worth everything we've
done that makes it all worthwhile right
there
yep and like I said for people to
support that it's military Outreach
usa.org
um Echo Charles yes you have any
questions hey do you ever think about um
revisiting your Taekwondo career and
getting your black belt or is that a
closed chapter that's a clo at at 79 I
think that's a a little uh no but
seriously no I it would be something
you know if
I I think though i' I've slowed down and
I don't think I I do I wouldn't do
justice to the dojo you know and I I I
would not do anything that I didn't feel
I could really do 100% so you have
thought about it
then it's good to see you again sir okay
same here uh General any closing
thoughts well my Mantra every day is a
great day I have my faith my family
live in the finest country in the world
and I get a lot of sometimes feedback
about the finest country in the world
thing and I tell people listen I've been
around the block a few times
when you know I've seen an
African-American elected president of
our country and
reelected I've seen an
africanamerican uh sec secretary two
secretaries of State male and
female I've seen
asian-americans succeed I've seen in my
lifetime alone major
changes attempts for our society to
improve and also to recognize the errors
of our past such as uh eliminating
redlining for Real
Estate uh also eliminating uh uh
intermarriage racial
intermarriage prohib
prohibitions uh I've
seen uh you know education
opportunities improve I've seen the
integration of our Armed
Forces uh you know the military was the
first
major organization in our society that
integrated under President
Truman and uh in fact when I was in the
military and I'm sure you you've done
this
too sometimes I found myself forgetting
the
race of my Soldier or the person I was
dealing with because after a while we're
all out of
drab you know and and so uh that was the
beauty part of of the military you know
it was a
meritocracy it it wasn't equal outcome
it was equal
opportunity and so I'm I so every day I
say that I say it every chance I get I
said it today at the restaurant when we
had breakfast I say it when I'm when I'm
talking to uh somebody online that I've
I've there there's been a problem with
something and but I always say every day
you know it's like the person on the
other line who's always hearing people
complaining and you know swearing at
them or whatever it just blows their
mind when I say it I said hey I know you
know you're not the problem you know
you're just trying to deal with the
problem um but I I really it it makes me
feel good when I say it because
literally guys I'm not kidding I've said
this thousands of times over the last
decade and I've not had one person tell
me you know I don't want to hear
that it's the other way it's I mean I
see smiles on people's faces or I see
surprise you know and then smiles and
that's it it gives me a good feeling it
it's like serving when when you serve
others you know it's you can see that
they benefit from it so and then also
hopefully they will serve others cuz
some somebody's gone out of their way to
serve
them so I you know well how can I be so
positive how can I not be so positive
based on my life
experience well sir it's an amazing
story and uh once again it's an honor to
have you back here an honor to publish
the book uh an an honor to be able to
write the forward for the book and just
thanks for coming back here thanks for
sharing your stories and your lessons
learned and most important thanks for
your service thanks for your service in
Korea thanks for your service in Vietnam
thanks for your service in the Army and
in the reserves and thanks for what you
continue to do today to help our
veterans and their families thank you
for everything sir well it's it's a
distinct honor and privilege thank
you and with that General moo mukama has
left the
building and definitely left us with
some lessons
learned some things to think about for
sure
and uh great book so there you
go not much more to say yep I would say
you awesome awesome to hear from him I
always uh with him I always think of you
know the saying uh it's not the size of
the dog in the fight size of the fight
in the dog so like him so being 54 and a
half
that's not big physically but to be that
effective that's when I think about that
okay if we're going to bring this up
sure he was talking about his friend
there's little thread I had to follow he
was talking about his buddy Don who we
went to ROTC with in Illinois and they
were broke remember this yeah and they
would go out and share one beer each
plus lobster sauce shrimp yep okay and
they divided one shrimp for me one
shrimp for you one shrimp for me one
shrimp for you here's the thing he's
five4 and a half yeah do you remember
how tall he said Don was 64 there's a
problem there if I was Don I would have
been like hey man like like my kids
would do that when my kids were little
it's not fair you know it's different I
would get two hot dogs yeah and they
would get one and they' how come you get
to cuz I'm three times as big as you are
you little gnat cuz I'm huge yeah yeah
that is a good point but that shows you
Dawn very fair guy very very fair guy
maybe you know the argument could be
made that maybe moo needed it more get a
little more jacked uh yeah maybe but I
don't know it is one of those things
where you got to kind of weigh out the
checks and balances a little bit CU you
64 he's big big guy small guy you know
there's certain element of hey I'm 6'4
I'm big if I don't eat enough I'm gonna
shrink yeah so you're gonna take
you know it's one thing to be like okay
I won't get my freaking calorie Surplus
today cuz we're going shrimp um and beer
but it's another thing to be like hey
like I kind of got to not go into
starvation mode yeah kind of a scenario
but I don't know
that's something I'm sure they work you
know what's an interesting part of the
book too is like the um it is what it is
like the Japanese saying for like this
is what you got yeah and there's a weird
dichotomy between like this just is what
it is which is almost just accepting the
way things are as opposed to like hey
I'm not going to accept this I'm going
to make something happen I'm going to
make the best out of this and it's just
because in life you know there's things
you can control there's things that you
can't control you know what I mean like
there's things you can control and
there's things that you literally can't
control usually the things that we can't
control is a lot less than we think and
we actually have a lot of control over a
lot more things than we think but when
you do get to something that you can't
control to be able to say yep it is what
it is and not worried about it move on
it's very similar to the Travis Mills
conversation about like hey there's
nothing I can do about this I can sit
here and contemplate it forever and I'm
not going to get the answer that dog
don't hunt the dog don't hunt I'm going
to move on I'm going to do deal with
what I got it is what it is and now I'm
carrying on there's also you could have
that attitude if you take that to an
extreme which I don't recommend all of a
sudden it's like well you know if I was
supposed to be uh getting hired at that
job or getting promoted then I would
instead of being like Oh I didn't get
promoted you know what what can I do to
fix it yeah so you got to pay attention
to what you can control what you can't
control and you should look at
everything your initial look at
everything should be like I can control
this and then have the world prove to
you that no actually you can't yeah like
like oh I can I can do better with this
well actually that's your whatever you
can't control that okay and eventually
you realize yep can't control I'm not
going to worry about it move on it is
what it is so awesome stuff um by the
way speaking of eating shrimp or food
sometimes you need to up that c caloric
intake sometimes you need some protein
yes I recommend you get some milk from
joof fuel joof fuel.com get yourself
some food we don't have lobster sauce MK
and I don't think we ever
will maybe Peete might like that cuz you
know he likes lobsters a lot oh yeah he
does like lobsters so he might be like
yo that's a good idea let's make lobster
Lobster MK yeah he'd be more like a
chowder you know how like oh New England
clam chowder right but as yeah as far as
like the FL cuz like look MK is like a
dessert like a chocolate milkshake is
like a chocolate milkshake right vanilla
milkshake banana milk like it's like a
dessert but you get the the lobster MK
that's like a um a chowder a lobster
chowder flavor you see what I'm saying
so it's a different drinking
would you warm it up warm it up oh no
kidding think so so there you go joof
fuel.com you can get hydrate you can get
greens you can get the you can get the
go the the energy drink which is
actually good for you all the joint
Warfare joint health stuff that you need
there you go check it out joof field.com
you can also get it at WWA you can get
vitamin shop GNC military commissaries
AP Haner Das stor wake F Sho right HB
down in
teas crushing thank thank you everyone
in Texas for rolling into HB and getting
after it same with Meer up in the
midwest same thing thanks to you all
Harris Teeter let's make it happen
Lifetime Fitness Shields and then listen
if you got a gym you got a Jiu-Jitsu gym
you got a CrossFit gym you got a
powerlifting gym you got an Olympic
lifting gym you got a yoga whatever you
got you want to sell joof fuel email JF
sales joof fuel.com get in the game give
your clients what they need to get
better joof fuel.com go get
some also origin USA boom you training
the jits mhm could you use origin geese
in
Taekwondo depends on the teacher I have
no idea yeah I have no idea either
nonetheless we're doing Jiu-Jitsu anyway
so yes origin USA that's where you can
get your American ma everything by the
way but yes Jiu-Jitsu GES rashguards the
hoodies I feel like the hoodies don't
well the heavy hoodies but you know the
tradish origin hoodies have you ever had
to admit when you're wrong yes I do too
times I got one for you what so you know
we got the heavy hoodie it's cool I mean
and if you're from Maine or Minnesota or
Michigan or Montana yeah you're going to
need that heavy hoodie that heavy yeah
but I've always been kind of let's just
say against a lightweight hoodie hoodie
oh yeah hey what would you say okay so
there's the kilo hoodie I would consider
that medium weight okay and then there's
one more hoodie from origin
USA I can't even remember what it's
called it's the other one it's like
standard issue or something like this
but it's a little lighter but damn that
thing is like perfect for a lot of
scenarios that's the one so to me my
scale is one down you know like you know
how sizing chart can be like shifted
depending on your region but to me the
kilo is heavy mhm and then the heavy is
like Ultra heavy like there's there are
very few circumstances that I'm going to
wear the heavy I wore the heavy
snowboarding the kilo is made for
California a lot of ways that
temperature so the temperature in San
Diego it's 70° in the day it's 50° at
night kind of that's like yearound
situation right yeah uh because the
thing is in the desert which which San
Diego is a semi- a desert when the Sun
goes down it gets cold gets cool let's
say at a minimum you know it can be it
can be 35 degrees you wake up there' be
frost on your car right that can happen
in San Diego but even on a summer night
it's like 50° 53 degre at night you know
if you're outside and you're whatever
you're going to want that you're going
to want that kilo kilo but the light one
that you're talking about you're still
calling it lightweight I think that's
medium it is mediumweight it is medium
weight it is but it's it's a good like
1.5 yeah layer good one it's good one to
have in there so check it out get
yourself a hoodie get yourself an
americanmade hoodie don't just go buy
something from a from a damn slave labor
camp sweat yeah sweat shop hoodie don't
just don't buy one of those buy an
americanmade one 100% oh yeah don't
forget the jeans too multiple different
colors it's true it's true that means
and uh so the Delta 68 one too and we
talked about this before but not as much
as compared to how significant it is and
that's the stretch the functionality of
Delta 68 jeans very good you can do deep
squats with 100% you can do literally
anything yeah if if you were a if you
were a yoga person yeah you could do
yoga if you were a ballerina you could
do ballet bro KN knees over toes guy
yeah can wear that thing during his
demonstration yeah during his fun when
he's when he's squatting or dunking he's
got some he's got some hops some hops
there yes sir multiple knee surgeries
yeah man but he's getting hops yeah
that's impressive yeah and he can wear
the Delta six and he's not a spring
chicken either right how old do you
think he is is oh I don't know mid-30s
yeah he's not 20 something I don't think
no I don't think he's 20 something but
he's dunking yeah kind of with EAS too
kind of like powered up well he said
though he said he has a 42 in vertical
which is massive by the way so here's a
little uh trivia you didn't know about
me I had the highest vertical on my
first year my first year at University
of Hawaii football at the highest
vertical on the 39 and a half damn yeah
what is it right now oh
one maybe two on a good day it's not
very high but yes yeah so 40 you work on
it or was that just I didn't I didn't
have any training program no but I liked
like jumping around and doing stuff and
actually G literally growing up in our
elementary school and high school like
in the the there were the there were
these outdoor hallways and as the
hallways would kind of go through the
school there places where you can jump
and touch the beams that go across and
different hallways had different height
of beams so the one I remember
Elementary School the one going in the
cafeteria had the highest beam nobody
could touch it and I was but I always
and I ended up I ended up touching when
I used to train Dean a lot for MMA we
had in the upstairs area of city boxing
going to die they had like lights above
us and then like a beam and then a pipe
and there were different heights yeah
yeah and I would make him just like I'd
be like touch the beam and he would just
but it wasn't just one jump it would be
like touch if it was the I think the
lowest thing was like the the beam I
think was the lowest thing so but touch
the beam he just have to sit there and
like jump jump jump jump but be like
exercise training you know like during
like sprawls and then grappling and i'
be like all right touch the beam and
he'd stand there jump jump jump jump and
like touch the touch the pipe and the
pipe was like higher so he had to like
kind of and then touch the light and
he'd have to like full on jump but yeah
had jumping is freaking legit so good
for you so you had the 39 and a half 39
and a half Y and knees over toes is at
42 42 yeah any to well what they're
saying is like that's impressive
anything over like 36 is impressive like
even the basketball player and I was
only like what 510 5'11 so basketball
players don't need a 40inch vertical
even though some guys actually the
freaking there's this guy um freaking
Aaron Galloway was his name call you
call him the helicopter that was his
name basketball player he's like 66 68
or something like that 48 inch vertical
BR he could just dunk like it was so it
was very very impressive there was a kid
with when uh I lived in
Coronado there was a kid he was like in
the summertime he was probably his
junior year in high school yeah and he
was you know I'd see him out there he'd
be doing sprints and then he had
remember those shoes that had like the
toe pad yeah yeah and he would go and
train for like an hour with those things
yeah and his goal was like he was going
to dunk his senior year I don't know
what ever happened to this kid but but
he was he by the end of summer he was
slam dunking right know there's a
difference right between dunking and he
wasn't that tall he's probably he's
probably 6 feet but he was slam dunking
you know what I mean by the end of
summer I never I didn't calculate in the
beginning so it's something that you can
definitely improve at well yeah I mean
especially the knees over toes guys cuz
he guy cuz he said his vertical was like
19 or something like really bad or 21 he
he said he more than doubled it so okay
that was his Jam so yeah you can train
it and in fact there's there was this
apparatus it it was uh it came out it
was it was a big thing for gyms where
you could stack plates on it it was
almost like a Hammer Strength machine
for squats but then instead of just
squats You' do jumps on them so you
could load weight and do jumps with the
pads on your shoulders you know okay so
you you could do that with a bar but
you'd hurt your back and neck and
shoulders possibly you could yes this
was uh you know what Hammer Strength is
right those those machines they're just
they're just leverag there's no chains
or pulleys they're just it's more
leverage so um it's that essentially but
it's a you you stack the plates on the
on the back on the little thing and then
you put this should you know like a
squat not squat um calf raise machine
where you're underneath the pads on your
should kind of resembles that but it's
Hammer Strength is and you're jumping
and you're jumping and then you can put
your feet up on this little incline part
on it too did you do that cuz you were
like trying to get that vert no I I got
I already before that was introduced to
the training facility I was at at uh
um I had already had a high vertical so
yeah I did it for a little bit to
improve it but it I didn't do it
consistently enough to improve anything
plus we didn't test vertical after that
so who knows explosive power yeah it's a
good thing is a good thing all right
well there you go you can do all that
with a pair of Delta jeans on yes you
want you can they look good too buy way
yes origin USA All American made huge
deal also Joo has a store called Joo
store that's where you can represent
discipline equals freedom on your shirts
and hats and hoodies and shorts even got
fight shorts on there board shorts also
on the Joo store there's a thing called
the shirt Locker if you don't know about
this a different design every month new
shirt new design every month people seem
to like it I know people who that's
literally their whole wardrobe shirt
Locker shirs yeah Jamie's Dad for one
there you go he's representing oh yeah
full on check uh Jo underground.com
check that out uh we have another little
podcast that we do on there we and we we
own that platform so no one can ever
censor Us in any way check that out
don't forget about YouTube don't forget
about psychological warfare don't forget
about flips side canvas Dakota Myers got
that company making cool stuff to hang
on your wall the books faith family and
flag memories of an unlikely American
Samurai Crusader let's face it that's a
good subtitle for a book that is by what
you just heard from General James moo
Muk ayama the book's great all kinds of
good information in there and check it
out get it it's available on Amazon and
then I've written a bunch of books you
know what they are there's a new edition
of leadership strategy and tactics out
the field manual get that expanded Ed
dish and then you know the rest of the
books the kids books get the kids get
the kids you know the books so they have
a code to live by also Eon front we have
a leadership consultancy we solve
problems through leadership Golam
front.com if you need us to come into
your organization or if you want to come
to one of our Live Events events that's
how you do it also we have a a online
training academy for leadership
leadership in not just in business not
just on a team but in life so check that
out extreme ownership. and if you want
to help service members active and
retired you want to help their families
you want to help gold star families
check out Mark Le's mom mama Lee She's
Got an amazing charity organization if
you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to America's Mighty
warriors.org don't forget about heroes
and horses. org I'm G to check in with
Micah who's probably just come well he
came out of the field a little while ago
but we'll see how many you know mountain
lions he was able to track down and kill
with his bare hands also Jimmy Mays got
an organization beyond the brotherhood.
org check that one out and finally of
course from today's
guest check out Military Outreach
usa.org all great organizations we
support them and we hope you do the same
name if you want to connect with us on
the interwebs echo's at Echo Charles I
am at Joo willink just just be careful
cuz the algorithm is looking to grab you
and you can't blame the algorithm you
can't blame it you can't blame it it's
like people that are afraid of AI dude I
will unplug your machine you know what I
mean that what you're going to do you
ever see me with a plug I'll unplug you
you know what I mean people talking
about AI they're afraid of AI wait until
I rip that 110 out of the socket watch
you fre up son 220 220 whatever whatever
it's running kill its generator like you
know such a simple pragmatic solution
there or put water on it you know get a
little water yeah go go throw your
iPhone in the sink and see how how that
works for you all right so watch out for
the algorithm but it's not a monster you
can kill it you can unplug it yeah rip
the rip the plug out of the socket
you'll be good thanks once again to
General M mukama for joining us all
always appreciate you your service and
thank you for sharing your Lessons
Learned thanks for writing an amazing
book thanks to all our military
personnel out there tonight especially
our Vietnam veterans who fought in such
terrible conditions with very little
support from our citizens in this
country thank you for what you did and
thank you for your service and sacrifice
and also thanks to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service and all First
Responders thank you for your dedication
on the home front to keep us safe and
everyone else out
there so many lessons and one of those
lessons is to have a code to live by a
code a code that can guide you and help
you make decisions and help you do the
right thing that's why I made the
warrior kid code so that kids can have a
code to live by and know what's right
and know what's wrong and let it guide
them let's grab a couple of Rules From
The mukama Family
Code oh always tell the truth try your
best in everything you do be personally
neat and
clean save your money and spend it wise
wisely do the right thing even if it's
unpopular be on time for appointments do
not brag about your accomplishments or
possessions do not be discouraged by
failure or disappoints
disappointments keep good
posture do not
slouch that's some of the rules and
they're all all good and they're simple
but they're not
easy have a code live by it and allow no
slouching and of course allow no
slack and until next time this is EO and
Joo
out